So chat, jetzt kommen aber alle hier an den Start, instant hier, schon ein Jahr, ja ist
tatsächlich zwölf Monate, massive, eingestellt für zwölf Monate in folge, huge, benachrichtigung
regelt, ja auf Twitch kann man sich manchmal nicht verlassen, aber auf Discord funktioniert
die Benachrichtigung tatsächlich mit am besten, manchmal braucht Twitch ein bisschen, also
das dauert teilweise bis zu 5 oder je nachdem was los ist sogar noch länger bis es dann
angezeigt wird, 13 Monate, exzellent, big brain subs heute wieder, so, glaubt's gar
nicht, ah Mist, ich hab das Handy nicht hier, jetzt könnt ich es euch zeigen, ich war gestern
tatsächlich im Freien, ja und als ich so durch den Wald gelaufen bin, bin ich an einem Turm
vorbeigekommen und an diesem Turm hing quasi 5G oder was auch immer, irgendwelche Antennen,
jetzt weiß ich endlich wovon sich Corona verbreitet bei uns, das muss von diesem Turm ausgehen,
ich hab keine Ahnung ob das wirklich 5G war, was da am Turm hing, aber das war ein Turm
mit Antennen und Schüsseln und Zeugs, hab extra ein Foto gemacht, dass wenn ich Corona
kenne, kann ich sagen der Turm ist schuld, was die meisten Leute glaube ich nicht so
ganz kapiert, Moment, die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, das geht mir auf den Keks,
ich suche immer Musik ohne Vocals, aber dann ist teilweise trotzdem mit Vocals, na gut,
das erkennt man auch irgendwie an der Form der Antennen, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich
erkennt man das an der Form der Antenne, ich weiß es nicht, wie war eigentlich, ich hab
das überhaupt nicht mehr verfolgt, hat jemand mitgekriegt ob es jetzt diese Demo in Berlin
gegeben hat und wie viele Leute da waren, ich hab das überhaupt nicht verfolgt, was wollte
ich jetzt sagen, genau und neben diesem Turm, das ist auf so einem Berg oben, so 53 Meter,
also das ist nicht ein riesen Berg oder so, aber da oben ist ein Restaurant wo man futtern
kann, da war ich essen und die Leute haben sich dann auch unterhalten dort über Antennen
und so was, nach dem Motto da wirst du verstrahlt und solche Dinge, das war ja lustig, weil
ich glaube und dann hatten sie es auch davon, irgendwie von WLAN und sonstige Geschichten
und was hast du und GPS und noch alles, ich glaube viele Leute haben nicht verstanden,
dass viele Systeme, die man so verwendet, sei es GPS, sei es vielleicht hat noch irgendwie
einer Fernseh über Antenne, Radio, sonst was, dass die nichts senden, sondern nur empfangen,
ihr Demoverbot wurde gekippt, das weiß ich, aber die hätte doch gestern sein sollen,
oder?
Was war denn da gestern?
Ah ne, ist die heute erst, ne Moment, wo, was ist denn die?
Ok, war die gestern?
Entsetzen über Eskalationsamreihe, ok, wer ist da wieder entsetzt?
Mehrere von ihnen versuchten den Reichtag zu stürmen, aha, ok, der Hype Train, exellent,
Linky Train, 4 Monate, Dankeschön, Hyper, ne das ist, 4 Monate ist noch nicht Hyper Subscriber,
das ist nur, Moment, ist das Prime, ne, Dankeschön, also ich hab's mir nicht angeguckt, ich hab
wollt bloß wissen, ob's stattgefunden hat, ich verfolge das, ich verfolge das nur am
Grande, weil ich, so quasi in der aktuellen Lage, keine der Seiten für wirklich zurechnungsfähig
halte, also Leute, die die Welt nüchtern betrachten, nach Möglichkeit halbwegs objektiv
so wie sie ist, sind heutzutage in der Minderheit, also, die meisten Leute wollen gerne, dass
die Welt total einfach und schwarz und weiß ist, dass du alles in irgendwelche Schubladen
stecken kannst, das ist halt nicht so, der größte Voll-Dap kann mal was Sinnvolles sagen,
ja, oder der größte Big-Brain-Mann kann auch mal Übelsten-Blödsinn erzählen, ja, also
ich wollt einfach nur wissen, ob das stattgefunden hat oder nicht, auf Twitter guck ich nicht,
auf Twitter guck ich mir sowas nicht mehr an, vieles guck ich mir gar nicht mehr an,
also ich hab mein Twitter auf Andorra gestellt, dass ich mir den ganzen Scheiß nicht mal
angucken muss, ich kann mir diese ganzen Rassismus und ach was da, Twitter wieder Disko, ich
kann mir diese ganzen Debatten nicht mehr geben, das geht mir voll auf den Sack, ja, also da
muss ich mir, wie gesagt, da nehmen sich auch keine Seiten irgendwas, die gehen mir alle
auf den Sack, ich will da mal in Ruhe haben, naja, also das Bau muss ich sagen, so bescheuert
ich das finde, also vom grundsätzlichen her, was da manche Leute von sich geben, so von
wegen es gibt keine Viren und 5G und was auch immer, da sammeln sich ja viele Leute, viele
unterschiedliche Leute mit unterschiedlichen Einstellungen, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn man
von irgendetwas überzeugt ist, ich hab da kein Problem mit, wenn da einer demonstrieren
geht für, ich mein, ich nicht, weil da müsste ich ja Real Life und unter Leute und sowas
sein, das mach ich ja schon allgemein nicht gern, aber wenn irgendjemand was vertritt,
soll der ruhig demonstrieren gehen, also ich find das vollkommen okay, dass die das
machen, unabhängig davon ob ich das jetzt, die Meinung jetzt teile oder nicht, kann doch
jeder machen, die können auch, die können genauso gut gegen Atomkraft für was auch
immer, das ist mir vollkommen egal, sollen sie, wenn sie davon überzeugt sind, sollen
sie demonstrieren gehen, deswegen, das ist ja nicht umsonst so, dass sie das dürfen,
das finde ich auch vollkommen korrekt, dass sie das dürfen, wo wir wieder bei meinem
einzigen, wo wir wieder bei meinem hauptsächlichen Kritikpunkt sind am Handling der aktuellen
Situation, da es viele Sachen entschieden werden, ohne sie zu erklären und ohne Grundlage,
weil es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass das Gericht wohl gesagt hat, ich hab's ja eben
nur kurz gesehen, dass das Gericht wohl gesagt hat, ey, Verbot ist nicht, also sprich, da
werden einfach teilweise Sachen entschieden, weil man jetzt was entscheiden will, ohne
Rückhalt, ohne Grundlage und ohne Erklärung und das heißt ja bei vielen Sachen, so vieles
wirkt recht willkürlich festgelegt, ich hab mit den meisten Maßnahmen überhaupt kein
Problem, wenn es nach mir geht, könnten die Leute noch viel mehr Abstand halten, also
ich wäre generell für so viel Abstand wie jetzt und zwar immer, aber man muss das ganz
halt ordentlich erklären und man braucht vor allem auch die passende Grundlage dafür
und das war in dem Fall ja nicht so, sonst hätte das Gericht ja auch nicht gesagt,
gibt's nicht, könnt ihr machen, was, wenn Max irgendwann mal demonstriert, dann läuft
er stattdessen ein Handlager mit einem Laptop plus Max Streamer rum, ja wenn schon dann
sowas ey, ich war in meinem Leben nur nicht auf eine Demo und das liegt nicht daran,
weil ich nicht von irgendwelchen Sachen überzeugt bin und will, dass sie umgesetzt werden, aber
ich hab mittlerweile ehrlich gesagt die Hoffnung aufgegeben, dass irgendwer, der in der passenden
Position ist, etwas zu tun, irgendwas in meinem Interesse macht, ja, das fängt mit Infrastruktur
ausbauen, das ist komplett im Arsch, das fängt mit Technologien an, wir haben so viele Sachen,
die mir voll auf den Sack gehen und also mein persönliches Fazit ist und ich will jetzt
aber nicht, dass irgendwer mir das sagt, ja genau so ist es, weil wenn jemand von Sachen
überzeugt ist, soll der ruhig demonstrieren gehen und machen, also ich für meinen Teil
bin mittlerweile auf dem Standpunkt, es sagen zwar alle, sie machen was für dich, aber
am Endeffekt macht keiner was und dementsprechend ist das einzige was man machen kann, dass
man, dass man so dumm und egoistisch das jetzt klingt, ja, aber das einzige was man wirklich
selbst machen kann ist, dass man guckt, dass es einem selbst gut geht, also sprich, dass
man unabhängig irgendwie Haus, Wohnung, sonst was hat, dass man genug Kohle hat, dass man
abgesichert ist, irgendwie in Bereichen, die einem halt eben wichtig sind und dass man sich
da so weit selbst darum gekümmert hat, dass man nicht darauf angewiesen ist, dass andere
irgendwas für einen machen, weil wenn man darauf angewiesen ist, dass andere was für
einen machen, dann ist man gearscht, sagen zwar viele, auch gerade wenn Wahlkampf ist
sonst was, sagen zwar viele so nach dem Wort, ja wir setzen uns für euch ein, aber ganz
ehrlich, guckt euch die Pflegekräfte an, wo sie erzählt, oder die Supermarktmitarbeiter
oder sonst was, haben gesagt, oh unsere Helden, die Pflegekräfte, oder gibt es jetzt voll
mehr Geld, bis jetzt nichts passiert, ja, also sprich, es wurde einfach nur rumgeschleimt,
dass die jetzt nicht einfach von heute auf morgen sagen, leckt uns, wir hauen ab, sondern
es wurde rumgeschleimt, aber im Endeffekt ist nichts passiert, also es sagen, es sagen
viele was, dass sie was für dich machen, wenn es ihnen gerade in den Kram passt, aber
unterm Strich, sobald die Situation vorbei ist, macht keiner was für dich, deswegen
ist das einzige, was du wirklich machen kannst, gucken, dass du dein Scheiß selber auf die
Reihe kriegst, und dass du so viel selbst in den Händen hast, wie irgendwie geht, hast
du dich nicht, medizinische Versorgung ist im, mir gefällt, ich muss ehrlich sagen,
es ist leider so, ja, mir gefällt es auch nicht, Taterify, das guckt ihr, guckt euch
medizinische Versorgung an, wie das abgebaut hat, wenn du gesetzlich versichert bist die
letzten Jahre, heute musst du quasi froh sein, wenn dein Hausarzt sich 2 Minuten 30
mit dir beschäftigt, weil du nicht mehr als einmal 3,50 Euro im Monat kassieren kannst,
und ganz ehrlich, das ist halt keine ordentliche Versorgung mehr, so finde ich zumindest, deswegen
mache ich jetzt bei allen Sachen, die mir wichtig sind, gehe ich wohin, wo ich den Kram
selbst bezahlen muss, genau wie lange, das macht, ja, ich habe ja auch noch einen normalen
Hausarzt, wo ich hingehe, wenn ich erkältet bin, oder irgendwie eine Krankmeldung brauche,
weil ich irgendwas habe, da gehst du hin zum Hausarzt und sagst, und dann sagt er, ja okay,
die sind krank, alles klar, ich sehe es schon, mein aktueller Hausarzt, der ist wirklich
super, insofern, dass da keine Sau hingeht, das heißt, warte ziemlich immer leer, der
ist auch schlecht, der ist wirklich der Sack, mega, der Typ, der untersucht dich auch nicht,
ja, aber ich gehe, der einzige Grund, warum ich zu dem gehe, ist, weil du bist saumäßig
schnell dran, und du hast deine Krankmeldung schnell, wenn was ist, weil ganz ehrlich,
wenn du erkältet bist, du kannst eh nichts machen, ja, was willst du großartig machen,
gehst du hin und sagst, ich bin erkältet, dann sagt er, okay, dann fragt er mich schon,
was meinen sie denn, weil es wieder gut ist, also ja gut, wahrscheinlich bis Ende der Woche,
wenn heute Mittwoch ist, sagt er, ja okay, liegt vorne und tschüss, es dauert, also
ich gehe da rein, warte fünf Minuten, bin dran, nach einer Minute bin ich wieder raus
und gut, es ist exzellent, wenn ich wirklich mal behandelt werden möchte, gehe ich da
nicht hin, da lohnt sich fast eine private Krankenversicherung, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß,
aber das müsste ich jetzt machen, also 35, 36 ist das, ist eigentlich so das letzte,
das letzte, wo es sich richtig lohnt, sowas zu machen, ja, würde sich lohnen, aktuell
ist es halt so bei mir noch, dass ich hab nicht oft was, und wenn ich was hab, dann
ist es was von, was von alleine wieder weggeht, ach so, by the way, bevor ich das, bevor ich
das, dass ich das andere nochmal fertig erzählen kann, also, warum ist YouTube eigentlich,
what the fuck, warum kann ich YouTube nicht dunkel machen, warum ist das eigentlich hell,
egal, ausgetrickst, lull, also, oh ja, noch mehr, noch mehr REC Videos, also, mein Doktor
hat mich noch nie untersucht, als ich dahin gegangen bin, also mein Hausarzt hat mich
noch nie untersucht, als ich dahin gegangen bin, hab gesagt, ich bin erkältet, also,
die meisten, die hören dich ja dann mal zumindest ab, um zu hören, ob du irgendwas schlimmeres
hast oder gucken dir meinen Hals oder so, macht er nicht, macht er nicht, deswegen geh
ich da auch nicht hin, wenn ich ordentlich behandelt werden willst, sondern einfach
nur, wenn ich krank bin und eine Krankmeldung brauch, also, ja, was wollte ich, genau, also
zum Thema private Krankenversicherung wollte ich noch was sagen, und zwar, dass ich bisher
halt kaum was hab, und die, was weiß ich, 350, sonst was, okay, es ist ja nur die Hälfte
im Endeffekt, weil der Arbeitgeberanteil, den kriegst du ja trotzdem, keine Ahnung,
ich sag jetzt mal 250 Euro im Monat oder so, das ist halt aktuell so, dass ich das vielleicht
im Jahr bezahle, wenn ich mal irgendwo hingehe und die Sachen selbst bezahle, also, ich bin
viel viel billiger, gesetzlich versichert, bloß ab und zu mal was selbst bezahlen, es
könnte natürlich sein, dass das gerade, wenn man dann irgendwie mal 60 plus ist oder
so, dass das dann zunimmt und sich dann gelohnt hätte, wenn man das gemacht hätte, ja, gut,
zumindest bin ich immer noch insofern gesetzlich versichert, dass ich nicht instant verrecken
muss, wenn irgendwo was ist, aber, ja, wahrscheinlich wird sich das lohnen, aber ich geh ja nicht
oft hin, ich hab ja auch wenig, ich hab ja auch wenig, aber, um jetzt mal den Unterschied
nochmal zu berichten, weil, es wird immer erzählt, so nach dem Motto, oh, wir müssen
aufpassen, dass das keine zwei Klassenmedizin und sowas gibt, haben wir, also, die Frage
für mich ist gar nicht, dass wir da irgendwie aufpassen müssen, dass es das nicht gibt,
sondern eigentlich ist die Sache schon beantwortet, es gibt, das ist sehr offensichtlich, also
ich weiß nicht, wer von euch vielleicht privat versichert ist oder wer von euch vielleicht
ab und zu mal beim Arzt, zu einem Arzt geht, wo er selbst bezahlen muss, würde mich mal
interessieren, chat, wie das bei euch so ist, aber, also, für Leute, die bisher
nur, sagen wir mal, bei den gesetzlichen Ärzten waren, und ich will nicht sagen, dass es da
nicht auch den einen oder anderen guten gibt, aber, die meisten, wo ich bisher war, ist halt
mittlerweile von der Versorgung her, dass es eher geht, möglichst schnell möglichst
viele Leute durchzuschleusen, dass es sich auch halbwegs rechnet und individuell auf
die Leute wird überhaupt nicht eingegangen, du wirst teilweise nicht untersucht, du kriegst
irgendwas und nach zwei Wochen wird geguckt, ob es dann weg ist, ach nee, dann war es
was anderes, also das beste Beispiel, was es arztechnisch gab, das war nicht bei mir,
sondern bei meiner Mutter, die hatte irgendwas an der Hüfte, ja, die ist jetzt 70, also sprich,
da kann man was an der Hüfte haben, und der hat quasi wochenlang die Hüfte wehgetan,
und das ist jemand, der geht nicht zum Doktor, ja, ach ja, übrigens, falls ihr gerade, nice
waist, ich weiß nicht, wie man das richtig ausbrechen soll, das gerade sagt, das ist
auch so eine Geschichte, Termin als Kassenpatient, haben Sie in zwei Jahren Zeit, tatsächlich
so, ich hab bei meinem Hautarzt, ich hatte mal so einen Ausschlag, kein Ausschlag, in
so einem dicken, irgendwas auf dem Kopf, ja, was man auch gemerkt hat beim drübergreifen,
da wollte ich meinen Hautarzt gucken lassen, und da hab ich in Hanau bei einem Hautarzt
angerufen, und er meinte irgendwie, ja, in, ich glaub, vier Monaten oder so, ich hab gesagt,
okay, in vier Monaten ist mir entweder der Kopf abgefault, oder es ist wieder weg und
kein Problem, ja, also hab ich bei einem Hautarzt in Frankfurt angerufen, hab gesagt, okay,
ich hab was am Kopf, müsste ich mal einen angucken, ich bezahle selbst, das war auch
eine Praxis nur für Privatversicherte, also sprich, mit Kärtchen wär da eh nix gewesen,
da war der komplett entgegengesetzte, da haben die mich gefragt, ja, wann passt's Ihnen
denn, Herr Max, wann passt's Ihnen denn, ähm, und hab gesagt, ja, also, jetzt bin ich grad
auf der Arbeit, ich könnt dann, ich könnt dann nachher, nachher vorbeikommen, aber es
wird vielleicht zu spät, und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, wie sieht's dann, wie sieht's
dann morgen so, morgen 15 Uhr aus, würde, ja, wunderbar, das ist das komplett, komplett
Tag und Nacht Unterschied, ja, ähm, Flo690, das hab ich gar nicht so verfolgt, wie das
mit diesen Versicherungen aussieht, was, also, eine Sache, die ich persönlich wirklich cool
finden würde, ist, wenn man mit seiner gesetzlichen Karte, oder nicht mit der Karte, wenn man,
wenn man zu einer Privatpraxis gehen könnte, ähm, dort sich behandeln lassen könnte,
und man den Teil, den, sofern das eine Behandlung ist, die die gesetzliche Kasse abdeckt, dass
man den Teil quasi von seiner gesetzlichen Kasse wiederbekommt und den Rest selbst bezahlt,
das wäre so die, so für mich die, die, die, die geilste Lösung, wenn's sowas, wenn's
zumindest sowas in der Richtung gäbe, ja, das einzige, wo's aktuell praktiziert wird,
sowas in der Richtung, ist bei, hab ich gelesen, bei, bei Psychotherapien und sowas, die wollen
nicht für den lächerlichen Kassensatz arbeiten, das heißt, nachdem es keine Versorgung an,
an Psychotherapeuten gibt, ähm, bezahlen die gesetzlichen Versicherungen oftmals private
Sätze für Therapien, weil's kein Leute gibt, die, die das für den normalen Satz machen,
hab ich gelesen, das ist halt auch, das ist auch so ein Ding, weil die, die müssen ja,
wenn du da anrufst und sagst, alter, ich will zum Arzt XY, da müssen, musst dir deine
Kalkerkassen ja im Zweifelsfall sagen, okay, da kannst du hingehen, also, die, die müssen
dir ja auch Ärzte nennen und, und, äh, da im Zweifelsfall auch einen Termin machen
oder ermöglichen, wenn du sagst, bei dir gibt's keinen, also, die haben schon, oft,
weil du da versorgt bist, zumindest, was ich, was ich jetzt eigentlich erzählen wollte,
mit, mit der Hüfte von meiner Mutter, also, riesen Unterschied, echt ohne Scheiß, ich
war ja vorher schon mal bei ein paar Ärzten, wo ich selbst bezahlen musste, hab halt bisher
da nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht, außer, außer, der eine hat mich übelst jebaitet,
aber, aber, Hardcomment, und zwar war ich, äh, in Frankfurt bei einem HNO-Arzt, weil
irgendwie mein eines Ohr verstopft war, ist auch, ist auch vorstellbar, ist so genau,
jetzt muss man das jetzt gar nicht wissen, aber, da bin ich hingegangen, hab gesagt,
hier, muss man mal, muss man mal gucken, und die hat nur dieses normale, das hat fünf
Minuten gedauert, den fünf Minuten sauber gemacht, und da war wieder hier, äh, exzellent,
äh, Hörfähigkeit wieder hergestellt, ja, so, überhaupt kein Ding, das hat fünf Minuten
gedauert, die hat einen extra Warteraum für Privatpatienten, dass die sich nicht über
den Weg laufen mit den anderen, dass die nicht merken, dass die anderen viel schneller
dran kommen, zumindest am Ende hat die abgerechnet, die Alte, 65 Euro, das hat fünf Minuten gedauert,
Alter, 65 Euro, und dann hab ich mir die Rechnung angeguckt, ja, und auf der Rechnung stand
drauf irgendwie, äh, diese, diese Reinigungsgeschichte, irgendwie mit 8,30 oder sowas, und was die
noch alles abgerechnet hat, äh, mikroskopische Untersuchung, Beratungsgespräch, alles mögliche,
totaler Schwachsinn, das hat die überhaupt nicht gemacht, also die hat mich, die hat
mich richtig gebaitet, da geh ich auch nicht mehr hin, ähm, ich hätte sagen können,
ja, ich bezahle nur den unstrittlichen Teil, und blablabla, für 65 Euro war's mir jetzt
nicht wert, aber die hat mich, die hat mich echt hardcore, 65 Euro, also das war wirklich
der teuerste, äh, da Besuch für fünf Minuten mal kurz gucken, was die gegeben hat, so,
also zumindest, ich hab bisher nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht außer halt bei dem einen, so, und
wie gesagt, meine Mutter hat's rumgequält mit ihr tut die Hüfte weh und konnte nicht
richtig schlafen und alles, ähm, wochenlang, so, dann ist sie zum, zum Hausarzt gegangen,
jetzt ist der, wo ich jetzt auch hingehe, der, der, der übel sackt, ja, und der meinte,
der meinte, der hat die gar nicht untersucht, der hat die überhaupt nicht untersucht, ähm,
der meinte, ja, das wäre Arthrose in der Hüfte, weil sie ist jetzt schon in dem Alter,
das muss Arthrose sein und das ist halt so ein bisschen belastet worden und dann entzündet
sich das und das muss, das muss Arthrose sein, ähm, sie hat gesagt, ja, okay, gut, der hat
wie gesagt nicht untersucht, einfach nur rein, gut, was soll er machen, aber mal zumindest
ein bisschen bewegen und gucken hätte man ja können, gut, ähm, so, daraufhin hat er,
und ich hab, ich hab damals schon zu ihr gesagt, hier, lass mal zu dem einen Autopäde in Frankfurt
gehen, da weiß ich, dass der ganz gut ist, muss was er selbst bezahlt, aber ich bezahl's
ja auch, ja, so, und danach hat sie nochmal einen Termin gemacht bei irgendeinem anderen,
äh, Autopäde, nicht Therapeuter, Autopäde meint ich, ähm, im, im Krankenhaus in Hanau
und, äh, der hat, äh, sie dann untersucht und hat sich schon gefreut, dass es Arthrose
ist, weil da hat er gleich gesagt, das können wir operieren, also sprich, der, der Dude
wollte, wollte einfach nur dicke Kohle, schnelle Kohle mit, mit Operation machen und da hat
er sie untersucht und hat nach drei Minuten festgestellt, oh nee, das ist keine Arthrose,
obwohl der, der Hausarzt quasi, da hat drauf bestanden, dass das Arthrose ist, quasi, ähm,
das wär was anderes und das geht von alleine wieder weg, so, und, dazwischen, das ist das,
wo sie dann auch im Krankenhaus war, weil ich, weil ich letzten, wo ich auf Twitter gepostet
hab, scheiße, ich sitz grad im Krankenhaus Ende letzten Jahres, der Hausarzt hat ihr
dann noch ein paar mal so ein Schmerzmittel gespritzt in die Hüfte, was man macht, äh,
wenn man, äh, wenn man Arthrose hat, das ist irgendwie so abschwellendes Schmerzmittel
und irgendwie abschwellende Sachen und, ähm, was der überhaupt nicht beachtet hat, ist,
dass die an sich ja eh schon ein bisschen Herzprobleme hat und daraufhin hat, hat sie
mich angerufen, nachts um 23 Uhr noch was, hat sie mich angerufen und hat gesagt, hier,
mir gehts nicht gut und da haben wir mal Blutdruck gemessen, Puls, ja, den Puls von irgendwie
200 und haben den Notarzt gerufen, sind ins Krankenhaus und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
es lag an diesen zweimal scheiß Schmerzmitteln, die absolut nicht zu dem, also erstens unsinnig
waren für das, was sie hatten, ähm, also unsinnig für das, was sie wirklich hatte,
waren die zwei Schmerzmittel und sie waren auch noch gefährlich für das, weil sie eh
schon herzmäßig nicht so die Allerbeste ist, so, ähm, allerdings zu dem Zeitpunkt
wusste der Arzt nicht, dass es, also man kann nicht sagen, der hat sie wirklich falsch
behandelt, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt wusste der nicht, der dachte immer noch, es ist ein
entzündeter Arthrose im, im, in der Hüfte und dieses Medikament gibt man da wirklich
für, ja, aber alles in allem, ich bin mir sicher, hätte der länger als, hätte der sich
länger als zwei Minuten Zeit genommen und sich dafür interessiert, ähm, dann wäre
das, wäre das nicht soweit gekommen, so, und zumindest war es an dem Krankenhaus, da
lag es an der Wand, da war wieder alles gut, also es ist, es ist nicht schlecht, im Prinzip
kriegt sie jetzt auch ein paar Mittel, äh, für, für Blutdruckherz und sonst was, wahrscheinlich
war es sogar ganz gut, dass er im Krankenhaus gewesen ist, dass man sich das alles nochmal
angeguckt hat und, äh, jetzt, mit dem Zeug, was ich jetzt nehmen muss, ist es auch insgesamt
besser, also, es hat sich gelohnt, zumindest, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, was wir dann gemacht
haben, ist das, was ich schon seit Anfang an, seit der eine Woche die Hüfte wehgetan
hat, gesagt habe, ist, wir sind nach Frankfurt gegangen, äh, zum privaten Orthopäde, äh,
Orthopäde, wo ich gesagt habe, hier, der hat ganz gute Bewertung, der ist auch noch
im Hauptbahnhof um die Ecke, Chris Downhedge, 11 Monate, Dankeschön, exzellent Subscription.
Ähm, so, da sind wir hingegangen, ich kann, ich kann sogar mal, ich kann sogar mal Werbung
machen für den, weil, bei Frankfurt Ars, da, bei dem waren wir, und der ist wirklich,
äh, exzellent gewesen hier, oh, was ist denn mit der Seite los, zumindest bei dem hier,
der hat auch, der hat auch nicht umsonst gute Bewertung, der macht, glaube ich, drei Sprachen,
äh, Deutsch, Englisch, Italienisch, der sieht ein bisschen aus wie Kokona, ja, aber der
war wirklich gut, der rechnet auch nur einfachen Satz ab, also, das heißt, es wird auch nicht
ultra teuer, zumindest sind wir hingegangen, hat man, hat man vorher angerufen, äh, Termin
gemacht, ging natürlich ultra schnell, wie das so ist, wenn man privat, äh, bezahlt,
und, der hat sich das angeguckt, Ultraschall rausgeholt, Hüfte angeguckt, meinte, ah,
okay, das ist, das garantiert keine Arthrose, und auch, auch nicht entzündet, das wäre
irgendwas im, in irgendeinem Gelenk, so, und da hat er irgendwelche ultra krassen Einrenkmooves
gemacht, ja, das hat geknackst, alei, das klang nicht gut, ich sag's euch, er hat irgendwelche
krassen Einrenkmooves gemacht, und hat hier nochmal ein, äh, Entzündungs-, Anti-Entzündungsmittel
gespritzt, allerdings direkt dort an die Stelle, wo es entzündet ist, nur ein ganz kleines
bisschen, und ihr werdet's nicht glauben, wir waren eine Woche später nochmal da, und
es war fast weg, ah, und am Ende hat's gekostet 105 Euro oder sowas, ganz ehrlich, die 105
Euro bezahl ich gern, wenn man sich den ganzen Scheiß vorher erspart, ah, so, also so viel
zu meiner Erfahrung mit, mit, äh, hier Gesundheitssystem und sonst was, ich weiß, ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht, wie ich drauf gekommen bin, aber doch, ich weiß, wie ich drauf gekommen
bin, also ich bleib dabei, man muss, so dumm es, so dumm es ist, so leid es mir irgendwo
tut, das einzige, was man, was man wirklich so in der aktuellen Zeit machen kann, ist,
gucken, dass man seine eigenen Schäfchen im Trocken hat, und man kann sich leider nicht
drauf verlassen, dass irgend einer was in seinem Sinne macht, leider, ja, auch wenn
es viele sagen, dass sie es tun, spätestens, wenn die aktuelle Lage rum ist, machen sie
es nicht mehr, guckt euch das Gehalt von Pflegern und sowas an, da tut sich jetzt auch nichts,
ja.
Hast du danach eine Bewertung abgegeben, nee, gut, dass du mich dran erinnerst, äh, wollte
ich machen, habe ich aber nicht gemacht, wollte ich machen, weil der war wirklich gut, aber
ich hab ihn jetzt im Stream gezeigt, passt schon, also, ja, 20 Ways to Use Virtual Machines,
wat, Google Account Name liegt, na wie gesagt, ich hab ja keine, ich hab ja keine Bewertung
abgegeben.
Ja, Chris Donalds, das ist natürlich gut, es gibt es vereinzelt noch, was es gibt ist,
also was ganz gut ist, wenn es Ärzte gibt, die privat und gesetzlich, also, das machen
ja alle, aber, also, jeder Arzt, wo du gesetzlich hingehen kannst, der behandelt dich auch privat,
warum sollte er, wäre ja blöd, wenn nicht, dann kriegt er mehr Geld, ähm, aber, wenn
es so ein Arzt ist, der quasi einen relativ hohen Anteil an privaten Patienten hat und
ähm, auch gesetzliche nimmt und sich dementsprechend so ein bisschen finanzieren kann, ähm, da
gibt es ein paar, aber da musst du echt Glück haben, wobei da hast du halt auch, Wartezeilen
ist natürlich eh dann logischerweise nicht so, aber solange die Behandlung gut ist, ist
ja auch okay, ne, dntxRage, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub, Exzellent Subscription,
sogar, Moment, es war sogar, ja, naja, und, also, du kannst dich halt nicht drauf verlassen,
dass, dass du irgendwie da noch, dass, dass in deinem Sinne da irgendwas passiert, das
ist halt, das tut mir auch ein bisschen leid, so, wenn ich überlege, ähm, dass es halt
viele Leute gibt, die das halt nicht können, ja, wenn ich, wenn ich beispielsweise am Bahnhof
bei uns gucke, wie viele Rentner, Senioren, sonst was, mittlerweile Flaschen sammeln, äh,
wie viele Rentner, Senioren, sonst was, Leute da quasi im Supermarkt die Reste sich holen
und sowas, ähm, das sind Leute, die bräuchten das vielleicht, aber die können sich das
nicht leisten, ja, das, gibt's halt, gibt's halt auch genug, und, äh, gerade, what the
fuck, ach so, ja, ne, das war was anderes, ähm, gerade für die Leute tut's mir leid,
dass es halt sich so entwickelt hat, ja, gerade für die Leute tut mir das leid, weil das,
das sind dann welche, die, die, die eventuell 50 Jahre auch, äh, quasi gearbeitet haben
und letztendlich dafür gesorgt haben, auch mit, dass wir da sind, wo wir sind, und dass
denen so scheiße geht, naja, letztendlich, wie gesagt, ich, das einzige, was ich für
mich da als Fazit mittlerweile nach, äh, 36 Jahren, äh, auf dieser Welt, äh, für
mich da jetzt unterm Strich erkannt habe, ist, als erstes muss man gucken, dass man
selbst, äh, dafür gesorgt hat, dass man haltwegs da, gut da steht, ja, bevor man da an alle
möglichen anderen Sachen denkt und, und ihr kennt mich, ähm, wenn ich sag an andere Sachen
denken, ich, ich spende, also ich spende nichts an irgendwelche, äh, humanitären Sachen
und so, ihr wisst, ich kann Menschen eh nicht leiden, außer, außer natürlich den Chat,
das wisst ihr ja, ähm, das einzige, wo ich was spende, ist zum Beispiel bei uns ans Tierheim,
ich spende eh lieber, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, Menschen sind zum größten Teil, ich,
ich mag Menschen zum größten Teil nicht, so, und, warum soll ich, für Leute, warum
soll ich für was spenden, was ich eh nicht mag, dann spende ich lieber für unser Tierheim,
ist man mit 36 nicht schon halb Scheintod, äh, ja, ja, äh, Unmut, ja, so, so könnte
man das auch, ich finde, das ist ein bisschen einfach gesagt, ja, man muss sich auch mal
gucken, wo teilweise das Geld hingeht, wobei ich mir da auch nicht so wirklich sicher
bin, wo teilweise das ganze, die ganze Kohle hingeht, ich mein, dass wir nicht reich sind,
ist, äh, denke ich relativ offensichtlich, wenn man mal um sich guckt, also, wenn man
danach geht, was theoretisch im Durchschnitt jeder haben müsste, und guckt mal um sich,
wird man feststellen, ähm, die theoretischen Werte, was im Durchschnitt jemand haben müsste,
ne, also wenn du quasi das Vermögen insgesamt nimmst und durch die Anzahl der, äh, Bevölkerung
teilst, siehst du, dass sich das halt überhaupt nicht deckt mit dem, was jeder Zweite so hat,
aber das ist halt auch falsch gerechnet, ja, du musst die untere, die untere Extrem
weglassen und das obere Extrem weglassen und dann auch gucken, was ankommt, und dann wird
man feststellen, so viel Kohle hat der Durchschnittstyp hier nicht, aber Deutsche haben übrigens
kaum Vermögen, gibt's, äh, gibt's richtig gute, gibt's richtig gute Videos auch auf
Youtube für und, äh, ab und zu lese ich ja auch die ein oder andere, anderen Finanzartikel,
auch wenn es, auch wenn das Stonksthema was ist, was mich persönlich jetzt eher, eher
nervt, aber manchmal muss man sich ein bisschen mit, ähm, beschäftigen.
Deutsche haben kaum Vermögen, also, oder unabhängig jetzt von Haus oder, oder sonst was, halt
kaum, wie soll man das Eigentum nennen, ich weiß nicht, was das richtige Wort ist, ich
glaube Vermögen passt ganz gut, also, die, ich glaube, denn weit, ich glaube 60%, 60-70%
sind's glaube ich, es lagelt mich jetzt darauf nicht fest, ähm, ich glaube 60 oder 70%
in Deutschland leben quasi von, wie man so steht, von Paycheck zu Paycheck, also die
haben kein, die haben kein Vermögen und die haben dadurch auch keine Möglichkeit sich
irgendwie Vermögen aufzubauen, das heißt, die sind auch letztendlich auf Gedei und Verderben
darauf angewiesen, was man ihnen so, so gibt und, und was sie dann vielleicht auch mal für
Rente bekommen und so, also sprich, die können nicht selber richtig vorsorgen, also die haben
kein Vermögen und die können auch kein Vermögen richtig aufbauen, was natürlich, wenn die
mal in Rente gehen müssen, richtig brutal wird, weil dann kostet das doppelt, dann
hast du dann irgendeinen Typ, der hat 40, 50 Jahre gearbeitet, kriegt, äh, kack Rente,
kann nicht überleben und muss noch mal zusätzlich Geld kriegen, bloß die Rente muss er vielleicht
noch besteuern, also ein Riesenteil, das hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht, ja, aber ihr könnt
nachgucken, ähm, ich glaube, ich muss doch gucken, ob ich das Video zu finde, aber es
ist schon krass, wenn man sich überlegt, dass du ein Riesenteil hast, die arbeiten gehen,
aber gar nicht die Chance haben, irgendwie ein bisschen Vermögen aufzubauen, äh, übrigens
wenn man, genau, das stimmt, wenn man mal nach Italien guckt zum Beispiel, oder auch nach
Griechenland, da ist es so, die Leute haben zwar im Durchschnitt, verdienen die vielleicht
nicht so viel, aber die haben ganz gern mal irgendwelche Häuschen und sowas, hat man
ja hier auch nicht, weil Deutschland so ziemlich das einzige Land ist, wo sich Häuser bauen
und generell Häuser kaufen und solche Sachen nicht lohnt, ich hab letztens ein Video zu
dem Thema geguckt und da meinte, es gibt wohl irgendwie so ein, wie gesagt, BWL-Stonkszeug,
ja, nicht meins, meinte, es gibt wohl irgendwie so ein Standardwerk, wenn es um Investitionen,
Geld, sonst was geht und, ähm, da steht wohl drinnen, dass es sich immer lohnen würde,
quasi, ähm, ein Haus zu kaufen auf, äh, also quasi einen Kredit aufzunehmen und ein
Haus zu kaufen, weil, also, klang auch logisch, was der gesagt hat, weil, anstatt Miete zu
bezahlen, kann man den Kredit abbezahlen und, ähm, danach gehört einem das Haus. Klingt
logisch, aber in diesem, also, steht wohl Fußnote drunter, gilt für jedes Land außer
Deutschland. Das ist auch geil, was ich meine, ja, zu überall bloß in Deutschland nicht.
Ja, naja, naja, gut, wenn man während dem Studium von Gehalt zu Gehalt lebt, ist das
jetzt was anderes, ja, aber wenn man sich überlegt, dass das halt einen großen, großen,
Großteil der Bevölkerung macht, ist halt, äh, ja, also, mir, also, mir tut's wirklich
leid um die Leute, die 50 Jahre gearbeitet haben und, äh, ich meine, ich seh's ja immer
hier bei uns am Bahnhof auch, äh, die nicht über die Runde kommen und, äh, quasi essen
teilweise schon, äh, also, die nicht nur Flaschen sammeln, sondern noch teilweise gucken, ob
hier Müllessen ist und sowas. Das ist eigentlich was, das sollte nicht sein und wir haben ja
auch genug Baustellen, wofür man die Kohle verwenden könnte, ja, sei es in die Rentner,
wir haben Infrastrukturausbau, sei es Straßen, Internet, Kanalisation, was auch alles, also,
man kann Geld sinnvoll ausgeben, aber irgendwie müssten wir unterm Strich, also, wir müssten
eigentlich viel Geld haben, aber irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, haben wir nicht viel Geld
und das sieht man ja auch, wenn man sich die Leute so anguckt.
Mir tun die Leute leid, die Lebensversicherung abgeschlossen, keine Ahnung, je nachdem wann
die die abgeschlossen haben, ist es vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Also, wie gesagt, ihr wisst ja, ich arbeite bei einer Bank und, äh, die Leute erzählen,
also, die ganzen, die, die, die, die Stonks Außendienstleute erzählen sich heute immer
noch, wie geil es war, als man die Leute Lebensversicherung verkaufen konnte.
Einfach nach Medira, Medira, Medayama, Daira, wie man das ausspricht, Auswander, ja, kann
man machen, oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, auf die Philippinen oder so, wo es billig
ist, ähm, kann man aber auch nur machen, wenn man, äh, die nötige Kohle dafür hat.
Weil nicht jeder hat die Möglichkeit, äh, von den Philippinen aus Geld zu verdienen
und, äh, ähm, würde das Geld, was du laut Rentenbescheid bekommst, Abzug der Steuern
reicht, abgesehen von der Inflation, äh, nö, nein, äh, ich, ich habs, ich habs euch
doch, ich, ich habs letztens im Stream sogar mal erzählt, ich hab nen Rentenbescheid bekommen,
was da drauf stand, das war nicht viel, 2000, 2000 Euro, im Jahr 2000, fragt mich nicht,
50 oder so, ne, also, ähm, 1800 Euro oder sowas, und da muss ich ja noch Steuern drauf
bezahlen, oder 2000 Euro, gut, aber ich meine, ich arbeite auch nur vier Tage und bezahle
nicht so viel, aber trotzdem, zumindest, bei mir, bei mir reicht's auf jeden Fall, äh,
ich persönlich hab auch nicht vor, bis, äh, 67 oder was auch immer, 70, was auch immer,
da zu arbeiten, gibt's heute Battlefield 3, ne, wir gucken uns, äh, wir, wir lassen,
ich lass mich zu ein paar aktuellen Themen aus, wir gucken uns ein paar Videos an, heut
kein Battlefield 3, ne, ähm, also bei mir kommt ja dazu, ich krieg die gesetzliche Rente,
ähm, ich krieg die betriebliche Altersvorsorge, und, gut, das krieg ich, glaub die betriebliche
Altersvorsorge krieg ich, glaub ich, ab 65 oder 67 und die Rente krieg ich dann, wenn
ich in Rente geh, ähm, da kommen ein paar Sachen zusammen, das ist an sich schon okay,
und dazu kommt halt auch, dass ich mittlerweile relativ viel Kohle noch, noch hier auf der
hohen Kante hab, weil ich halt nix ausgebe, ich geb ja für nix was aus, ich kauf mir
ab und zu mal nen Rechner für 3000 Euro, oder irgendwie, ich hab ein bisschen Technik, aber,
ähm, ich mach ja sonst nix, ja, ich mach ja nix großartig, was Geld kostet, ich mach
hier keine Weltreise, keine Kreuzfahrt, äh, irgendwie, irgendwie dreimal je mehr im Urlaub
fahren oder so, ich mach ja nix, was irgendwie großartig, äh, ich hab noch nicht mal, ich
hab noch nicht mal irgendwie ein großartiges teures Auto oder so, ja, musst eigentlich
mein, du hast Tribunal, du hast vollkommen recht, ich muss mein Geld anlegen, mir bleibt
gar nicht, ich, ich, ich, mir fällt's ultra schwer mich damit zu beschäftigen mit dem
Thema, ich müsste es anlegen, ja, äh, und dazu kommt, dass ich auch noch ein Haus hab,
also insofern, ich hab wahrscheinlich rententechnisch kein Problem, und äh, aus den Gründen hab
ich mir auch überlegt, dass ich garantiert nicht bis 65, 67 arbeite, oder 70 sogar, garantiert
nicht, ich werd mir das, also je nachdem, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie
das, wie das, äh, genau ist, äh, wie das, wie das reicht, ähm, ja, 55 ist auch so was,
was ich mir überlegt hab, genau, 55, am liebsten ehrlich gesagt mit 50, also sind noch 14 Jahre
Arbeit, so blöds klingt, aber, ähm, so unrealistisch ist es nicht, weil erstens krieg ich dann
später Rente, ich hab jetzt noch ein bisschen Kohle, ich hab mein Haus, und wahrscheinlich
erb ich auch noch ein bisschen was die nächsten Jahre, also, ist das möglich, ja, das, das,
das, das, das geht wahrscheinlich, das heißt ja dann auch nicht, dass ich gar nichts mache,
sondern einfach, dass ich nicht mehr dieses normale, wir stehen morgens auf, gehen arbeiten
mache, also sprich, sei es irgendwelche Videos, Streaming, sonst was gedürfen, da kann ich
natürlich weitermachen, das kann ich ja mit 50, da mach ich dann hier Opa Max, äh, owned,
äh, Junge Tryhards, äh, Battlefield 17 Stream oder so, wobei, nee, in 14 Jahren ist kein
Battlefield 17, da ist vielleicht Battlefield 9 oder so, ja, die sind ja nicht so schnell,
ja, und, naja, so, so siehts aus, nee, aber bis, bis 67 da, weil, also, warum mir auch
50 bzw. 55 vorschwebt ist, du fängst an zu malen wie der Opa, ja, die ganzen Bilder
hab ich ja noch, äh, ist, wenn man nämlich noch mal wirklich ein bisschen was machen
will, ähm, dann kann man das noch machen, ja, also, viele gehen ja in Rente und sind
schon so angeschlagen, v.a. wenn, v.a. wenn die 70, ich mein, überlegt mal mit 70, das
ist ja der Witz, du kannst, kannst du nicht erwarten von den Leuten, dass die arbeiten
von 20 bis 70, 50 Jahre und im besten Fall dann nach 10 Jahren den Löffel abgeben, das
dort, knackt, ja, kennst du noch diesen Opa, der damals Battlefield freigespielt, klar,
hallo meine Leute, oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, Wilhelm Kramer LP, klar kenn
ich den noch, beste, hallo meine Freunde, war das glaub ich, hallo meine Freunde, ja,
Speidel, das ist eine gute Sache, ja, weil mit 50 bzw. 55 auch kann man noch was machen,
Leute, die vielleicht mit 67, 70 in Rente gehen, ähm, und schon angeschlagen sind,
die haben dann gar nichts mehr von, großartig, und wo wir grad bei so ein bisschen philosophischen
Sachen sind, die, die, die Nummer eins Frage ist ja nach dem Sinn des Lebens, ja, und
ich will jetzt gar nicht zu philosophisch werden, sondern einfach mal ganz platt gesagt,
man lebt nur einmal, das sollten glaub ich allen klar sein, es sei denn man ist ultra
religiös, und, ähm, das beste aus meiner Sicht, was man machen kann, ist, dass man
möglichst viel Zeit dafür hat, was einem wichtig ist bzw. was einem Spaß macht, weil
niemand, bis auf vielleicht paar ganz verrückte, ähm, sagen, bevor sie die Löffel abgeben,
fuck hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet, keiner, gut, sag mal so, wenn du vielleicht ne Firma
gegründet hast, ja, und dann sagst, ok, ich hätte das und das machen sollen, das war
was anderes, aber, äh, wenn du einfach nur normal da arbeiten gegangen bist, oder irgendwie,
so, dann, dann wirst du nicht sagen, wenn du mal, ähm, keine Ahnung, wenn, kurz, kurz
bevor du vom, vom Stein erschlagen wirst, quasi, weil er dir auf den Kopf fällt und
du hast noch mal einen kurzen, äh, Moment, wo du dir jetzt sagst, fuck, da kommt ein
Stein, was hab ich in meinem Leben falsch gemacht, äh, oder richtig gemacht, dann wird
keiner sagen, ok, ich, ich kratze in fünf Sekunden ab, was hätte ich denn mehr machen
sollen, ah, mehr arbeiten, da sagt keiner, ja, keiner sagt, ich hätte mehr arbeiten
sollen, die meisten Leute sagen eher das umgedreht, die meisten Leute werden eher sagen,
hätte ich mal weniger gearbeitet, hätte ich mal mehr um meine Familie gekümmert, hätte
ich mal mehr, mehr Sachen gemacht, die mir Spaß machen, hätte ich mich mal mehr um irgendwelche
Hobbies gekümmert, hätte ich früher angefangen, die Sachen zu machen, die ich eigentlich machen
will, ja, hätte ich früher angefangen, ähm, quasi, mehr ich selbst, äh, solche
Dinge, wenn die meisten Leute denken, ja, aber nicht hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet,
das ist, das wird kaum einer denken, ja, ja, das ist was anderes, Informatiker, ähm,
also, ich sag ja auch nicht, dass man dann, also mit nicht mehr arbeiten, meine ich nicht,
dass man nicht arbeiten kann noch, nicht noch Geld verdienen kann mit was, was man Spaß
macht, aber dieses normale Arbeiten, so nach dem Motto, ich stehe morgens auf, gehe auf
die Arbeit, arbeite dann bis, bis 16 und dann gehe ich wieder heim, ähm, das, das meine
ich, also sprich, es wäre ja auch total bescheuert, wenn man nen Job hat, bzw. nen Hobby hat,
oder Job, Hobby, ja, also wir interessieren uns ja alle für, für Technik IT-mäßig ein
bisschen hier, ähm, warum sollte man, warum sollte man mit, mit 65 dann sagen, nee, mach
ich jetzt gar nichts mehr mit, oder vielleicht verdiene ich auch kein Geld mehr mit, nee,
aber ich mein, dieses, dieses normale, äh, wie sagt man, nein, nein, nee, äh, wie sagen
die Arme immer, neun bis 17 Uhr, nein, two, five, nein, two five, genau, nein, two five,
ähm, das meine ich, das, das nicht, ja, ähm, genau, so siehts aus, Twitch-Zuschauer, genau,
das meine ich, so, äh, ja gut, ähm, ja, Tribula, es gibt viele, die sind, die sind
rentegegangen, haben seinen Löffel abgegeben, das muss ja auch nicht sein, ähm, und eine
andere Sache, wo wir, wo wir gerade dabei sind, die muss ich, die muss ich auch nochmal loswerden,
weil, weil, es hat letztens, es hat letztens irgendeiner auf Twitter geschrieben, ähm,
was war das, ich krieg, ich krieg das Ding, das, das, das, das Quote nicht mehr genau
zusammen, aber das ist was, was man, was man oft liest auf Twitter, oder generell, was
man oft so als, als Weisheit hört, das war so nach dem Motto, man, man sollte nicht so
viel, also sinngemäß, ja, das ist so sinngemäß, das was, was, äh, alle, äh, ab und zu mal
von sich geben, so nach dem Motto, äh, scheiß auf die Meinung anderer, so nach dem Motto,
hat er geschrieben, oder, oder, man sollte, er meinte, er meinte eigentlich, man soll
nicht so viel drauf geben, was, was andere von einem denken, ähm, wobei, das ist so,
das ist so, so eine Weisheit, die geben alle immer von sich, auch wenn ich die im Prinzip
richtig finde, ist das, finde ich, erster, zweiter Schritt, das kann ich euch mit 36
jetzt mal sagen, ja, ich finde, das ist erster, zweiter Schritt, der erste Schritt, dass das
überhaupt geht, ist, dass man mit sich selbst halbwegs zufrieden ist, wenn man, oder, oder,
nein, was heißt mit sich selbst halbwegs zufrieden, also, dass man, ähm, sich selbst, eben akzeptiert,
ja, ähm, das ist der erste Schritt, weil ansonsten klappt der zweite Schritt nicht,
dass man weniger drauf gibt, was andere sagt, weil, wenn man, wenn man selbst permanent
so am Zweifeln an sich ist, so nach dem Motto, äh, mache ich das gut genug, mache ich das,
äh, quasi so, wie, wie das ein anderer gerne sehen möchte, ähm, da, da, da bin ich auch
viel empfänglicher für irgendwie einer, der, der mich kritisiert oder der, der was schlecht
findet, was ich mache, ja, ähm, wenn ich allerdings selbst mit mir da irgendwie im
Reinen bin, dann kann man den zweiten Schritt machen und sagen, ok, ich scheiß mehr drauf,
was andere sagen, kommt das nicht von alleine, ja, aber manchen vielleicht schon, ja, also,
ich hab, also ich hab da, ich hab da ein bisschen gebraucht für, zum Beispiel, so, was, was
ich, wo sich wahrscheinlich einige damit identifizieren können, ich hab mich früher zu ganz vielen
sozialen Events gezwungen, ja, sei es als Weihnachtsfeier in der Firma oder so was,
und da war ich dann da, oder auch irgendwelche Projektabschlussevents oder so Zeug, da war
ich dann da und hatte überhaupt keinen Bock, und das haben die meisten Leute auch gemerkt,
dass ich keinen Bock da drauf hatte, so, und, ähm, und ich dachte damals immer, ok, das
macht man halt so, und irgendwann macht man sich mal so Gedanken drüber, ok, wie kommt
man, also da muss man erstmal selbst in sich gehen, wie kommt man überhaupt auf die Idee,
also wie, wie kommt man dazu diese Idee zu haben, dass man das so macht, das ist ja irgendwas,
was man so, während man aufgewachsen ist oder so gesellschaftlich mitbekommen hat, so nach
dem, und das macht man so, dann gibt's viele Sachen, die man eben im Kopf hat, wie was
richtig zu sein hat, ähm, aber es einem selbst irgendwie wieder strebt, das so zu machen,
und da zu dem Punkt muss man erstmal kommen, dass man sagt, ok, ähm, das ist, das ist,
das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung, dass ich das nicht mag, also sprich, dass man sagt,
ok, meinetwegen mag das gesellschaftlich so, so sein, aber ich kann doch für mich sagen,
das mag ich nicht, so, und wenn man das, wenn man das, wenn man das erstmal hat, ähm,
dann kann man vielleicht auch mal irgendwann sagen, ja, Leute, also, äh, Weihnachtsfeier,
Projektabschlussfeier, ihr wisst, äh, großartige soziale Events sind nichts für mich, ich
wünsch euch viel Spaß, ähm, und, äh, hat nichts damit zu tun, dass ich euch nicht mag
oder sonst was, aber, äh, ich, äh, komm da, ich komm dieses Jahr nicht, und das kapieren
die Leute auch, es gibt natürlich ein paar, die wollen das da nicht einsehen, so nach
dem, Max, das kannst du doch nicht machen, aber die meisten, habe ich gemerkt, die verstehen
das, wenn man das denen wirklich sagt, ähm, hier, ich hab keine, so große Menschenansammlung
sind nichts für mich, ähm, dann finden die das, ok, reagierst du noch auf, ja, wahrscheinlich
irgendwann, demnächst, wenn ich fertig erzählen bin, genau, und dann kann man irgendwann
sagen, ja, scheiß mehr drauf, was die anderen sagen, man sieht jetzt 50 Minuten fast, ja,
was soll ich machen, wenn ich gerade so am erzählen bin, ja, 50 Minuten, gut, was ist
das erste, was ist das erste Video, was wir uns angucken, Battlefield, wollen wir uns,
wir können uns ne Runde, Linux versus, oje, da kann ich wieder, da kann ich wieder meckern
hier, ähm, Moment, jetzt aber, kann mir einer erklären, warum der Button hier auf YouTube
nicht funktioniert, äh, no limit xo 4 Monate, excellent subscription, hast du schon New
World ausprobiert, ne, auch wenn ich so MMO-Fan bin, das ist ein Game, irgendwie spricht
es mir nicht so hundertprozentig an, ich weiß auch nicht, das lag glaube ich daran,
dass, dass im Vorfeld so viele Berichte kamen, dass sie während der Entwicklung die letzten
6 Monate alles umgestellt haben, aber, ne, warum geht der Button oben nicht, was ist das
für ein Scheiß, geht der im Chrome, was, ok, ich weiß nicht, was ich da aufhör, ich
bin auf YouTube, im Chrome geht er, hast du schon Guild Wars 2 gespielt, ja, vor Jahren,
warum geht der Scheiß-Button nicht, na gut, ok, was, was kann man anfangen, ähm, Epic
Battlefield, komm, wir gucken mal wieder ne Runde Battlefield, wir gucken mal wieder
ne Runde Battlefield, erstmal die ganzen Tabs neu laden, aber wir können uns auch das neue
Electro-Boom-Video angucken, die sind auch immer geil, setting up the perfect Windows
10 installation, ah, excellent, ok, ich glaub das ist nicht so spannend, achso, haben wir
das das letzte, ne, das haben wir das letzte Mal nicht geguckt, ich hab das letzte Mal
nur gesagt, weil es Geld bringt, komm, wir gucken uns ne Runde Battlefield an, das, das
muss jetzt mal, muss jetzt mal einstieg sein, excellent, Moment, es läuft das überhaupt
auf, Highly Tales, ja, danach gucken wir uns das Electro-Boom-Video an, ja, C4 in, sag
mal, ist der komplett, Prane of K, was macht der da, warum braucht der da drei, das hab
ich jetzt nicht kapiert, was war, was war, was war da dran jetzt Epic, was, das muss
ich nochmal, was, was war daran jetzt Epic, er legt da nen C4 hin, ja, ok, ach, das ist
noch nicht fertig, ah, Bad Company 2, Jack-Frags, könnten wir uns angucken, what the fuck, Battlefield
die Logik, achso, achso, aber man kann auch Leute killen, während sie in der Messer-Animation
sind, achso, jetzt hab ich's verstanden, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
Ich muss nur so ein kurzes Video hochladen, aber ich muss alle wahren, kauft euch auf gar keinen Fall!
Metal of Honor Warfighter, wir gucken uns jetzt diese Szene gleich nochmal in Zeitlupe an.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie dieses Game überhaupt auf den Markt kommen konnte.
Das ist der größte Bugs...
Guck zeich mal an, guck zeich mal an!
...Scheiß, den ich gesehen hab, da ist Battlefield 3 und andere Spieler am Anfang nix dagegen gewesen.
Achtung! Gegner-Teleportation durch den Boden!
Jetzt kommt sie, Achtung! Achtung, Achtung, jetzt sterbe ich und jetzt kommt der Gegner...
Der kommt, der kommt, der kommt durch den Boden gefahren!
Der kommt durch den Boden gefahren!
Ohne Scheiß...
Und jetzt kommt der Gegner...
Der kommt, der kommt durch den Boden!
Ich kann mir das immer wieder...
Zu geil, Alter!
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt sterbe ich und jetzt kommt der Gegner...
Der kommt, der kommt durch den Boden gefahren!
Der kommt durch den Boden...
Gefahren!
Ohne Scheiß, das spiel ich doch nicht, weiter in den Dreck!
Zu geil!
Ich hab keine Ahnung...
Was sie da verkehrt programmiert haben.
Ich mein, klar, es war irgendwie Interpolation, die nicht richtig funktioniert hat, aber...
Keine Ahnung, was da genau gelaufen ist, ey!
Neuer Follower-Alert?
Der kommt durch den Boden gefahren, soll ich als Follower-Alert nehmen?
Eigentlich ist das eine gute Idee, das schreib ich mir mal auf.
Äh...
Das ist für mich eine gute Idee, das könnte ich echt als Follower-Alert einstellen.
Der kommt durch den Boden gefahren...
Nicht Follower-Alert, Follower-Alert, Sub, Sub-Alert.
Fall Follower-Alert ist es ja nervig, wenn das die ganze Zeit kommt.
Da hab ich, ich glaub, für Follower hab ich überhaupt keinen Sound.
Ähm...
Für, für Subs hab ich glaub ich nur Sounds.
Follower hab ich oben die, den, den, den Vogel, der.
Den da.
...
Tutututututu...
Die sind eben gerade durch den Rotor geflogen!
be seen in other games like this clip from jaredo as the megalodon is about to be summoned from the depths
of paracel storm completely flattening a friendly scout chopper oh cool das wusste ich gar nicht dass das geht
is about to be summoned aber das ist paracel storm oder ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig an erinnern an die sache mit dem high
das war paracel storm und das ist der flugzeugträger und er springt über den flug und der kaputt das kaputtene schiff da auf
jeden fall und er springt ist er ist er echt über den darüber gesprungen
war das immer die gleiche stelle ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern
war das nicht paracel storm doch doch das ist paracel storm das war so eine art easter egg ja
also easter egg ist zu viel gesagt also eigentlich ich sehe es in irgendwas was tun was nebenbei mal
am arsch der welt zufällig entdecken kannst als referenz auf was anderes aber das ist eher
ein secret eingebaut was gefunden werden wollte auf deutsch moment was zum moment
was war das moment das war eine trone der mit der trone die mine kaputt gemacht irgendwie sowas ja
kokona das das war nicht kokona das war mein fack wo ist mein emote hier das muss ich noch mal anhören kurz mit dem passenden emote dabei oder
auch nicht vielleicht war es vielleicht vielleicht habe ich den akzent auch falsch interpretiert
was ist happening excellent was
moment was
aber ich muss sagen es ist ich weiß ich habe die spiele gespielt haben es echt schwierig zu
zu zu folgen was grad passiert jetzt fliegt irgend ein panzer durch die durch die landschaft
gleich das oder eher ach nee da macht den heli mit c4 kaputt und und und und und nicht
doch gestern also ok also vielleicht vielleicht das ist legit ja aber dass der ausgerechnet da
landet also ja der software tröggen welcher software lese letztens habe ich bei uns in der
nähe war eben ein typ auf dem balkon und und hatte da seine software seine software waffen
gewähre stehen und dann haben irgendwelche besorgten nachbarn die polizei gerufen und
haben dort angerufen haben gesagt der nachbar steht mit dem gewähr auf dem balkon da sind
die da angerückt und haben geguckt warum da mit dem gewähr auf dem balkon steht da kam
halt raus das sind nur irgendwelche software software gewähre was die mann eigentlich
die müssen auch so gemacht sein dass man das erkennt ja so zumindest jetzt ist die
diskussion darüber entbrannt ob er diesen einsatz bezahlen muss oder nicht also ich
persönlich bin der meine muss er nicht man darf die sachen haben die dinger müssen so
dürfen nicht mal quasi es gibt ja so eine ich weiß nicht wie das heißt in zur regelung
dass du quasi dass du die waffen direkt erkennen musst dass es keine echten waffen sind das
muss er nicht bezahlen ich meine ich glaube es gibt es ich glaube es gibt kein verbot
dass du deine software equipment nicht auf den balkon stellen darfst
der trifft jetzt gleich was anderes ja das am arsch der welt da hinten den buggy oder
so getroffen und jetzt noch der pass auf jetzt noch den heli noch den heli noch den heli
was auch immer nein kenne ich nicht leku leku kenne ich nicht also ich kenne ich kenne ich
habe ja auch nichts mitgemacht das ist so ein remote so ein remote desktop gateway schon
die jugendwörter gesehen ornee hast man link die gucken wir uns an also ich muss sagen
dieses video ist irgendwie langweilig die sind sonst besser von dem das finde ich diesmal
nicht so gut das ist irgendwie resident sleeper da gucken wir uns lieber das bett company
zwei video von jack flax an
excellent
ja gucken wir uns gleich an jugendwort des jahres
im gamestop gamestop war schon immer der größte scam laden überhaupt ich weiß gar nicht warum
gamestop jemals so erfolgreich war so nach dem motto ja du kriegst neues game wenn uns
50 der alten games gibt gibt oder oder du gibst uns denn du gibst uns zehn alte games bekommst
3,50 für ich habe sogar ich habe sogar eine physikal copy of bed company eins
ist laut genug ja bett company zwei hat sich ziemlich gut verkauft ja und weil sich bett
company zwei so gut verkauft hat machen wir kein bett company drei big brain
ja das war auch gut
das war auch gut das beste an bett company zwei war rush und dass man es auch rush mäßig
spielen musste weil man gut man es gab immer noch schleiber am arsch der welt ja und das
gab auch unten wo sich nichts passiert aber du konntest mit einem mit einem squad sag
man mal aus 234 wenn vierer squad hat das die richtig gut gespielt haben und und gerusht
sind du konntest alles so zerbärsten das war das heftigste ohne bettel viel spiel fast
noch ein pass noch mehr als bettel viel drei du konntest hier so krass die gegner ohne
übertrieben heftig und das einzige game wo ich sniper gespielt habe
ich finde die haben es auch ganz gut gemacht war das halt häuser die nicht einstürzen
konnten und du hattest häuser die wo du gleich wusstest die können kaputt gehen ja das fand
ich fand ich eigentlich ganz gut hatten sie ein bett company hatten sie ein bettel viel
drei dann auch übernommen dass du quasi im bettel du konntest in bettel viel drei konntest
du diese häuser hier beispielsweise nicht kaputt machen häuser mit so einem speziellen
treppenhaus war nicht zerstörbar du konntest auf der treppe campen und die konnte nichts
passieren ich weiß nicht wenn ich bett company zwei oder oder bettel viel drei gameplay
sie das ist so da habe ich so so so ein gewisses gefühl was ich mit diesen beiden games verbinde
das kann man schlecht beschreiben aber es gibt paar games wenn ich an die denke habe
ich irgendwie so ein gewisses bauchgefühl das ist unterschiedlich von game zu game also
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise an bett company zwei und denke habe ich irgendwie ein anderes
bauchgefühl als wenn ich in ich weiß nicht wie ich das anders beschreiben als wenn ich
an bettel viel drei denke es gibt 99 prozent der games habe ich überhaupt kein gefühl wenn
ich an den namen denke ja wenn ich an so uralt an meinem os die ich ewig gespielt habe wie
dark edge of camelot denke habe ich auch ein gewisses gefühl was ich mit dem game verbinde
ja das ist erinnert mich halt wieder dran wenn man so videos guckt
also lohnt nichts ich weiß nicht auf was ich das bezieht aber da schreibt das jugendwort
des jahres ja aber ich glaube du meinst nicht das an was ich gerade gedacht habe aber der lost
hat es wirklich verdient erfolgreich auf twitch zu sein also das ist wirklich ein dem gönn ich
aber hat mit dem jugendwort nichts zu tun aber wollte ich jetzt nur mal noch mal anmerken dem
gönn ich das wirklich wie laut das immer zusammengefallen ist dieses haus das hatte aber
auch wenn du drin standst du hattest so instant dieses diesen reflex alle ich muss jetzt auf dem
nächsten fenster raus zumal du ja schon im haus verreckt bist bevor es eingefallen ist
ja wusste ich beste ja weil die nicht mehr in der lage sind ordentlich russ maps und
rush modus irgendwie zu machen die kriegen das nicht mehr gebacken wahrscheinlich weil
alle bett company leute weg sind bett company 1 bett company 2 und das meiste von battlefield
3 war richtig geile waschmaps auch auf auch die m platt battlefield 3 hatte fragwürdige
emcom platzierung zum beispiel sand crossing das erste das erste emcom in dem in dem hof auf der
linken seite ob ihr wisst was ich mein wo du quasi so gut wie nicht drangekommen bist wenn
er gegen gescheite defender also battlefield 3 hatte schon ein paar fragwürdige emcom locations
ja aber an sich waren die wirklich ok bett company 2 hatte halt eher so offene landschaftsmaps mehr
spielte hardcore warum sterben die leute so schnell spielte hardcore die leute sterben
bett company 2 normalerweise nicht so schnell port walters beste port walters ne das ist nicht
port walters das ist cold war hier na port war oder moment das ist doch port walters das könnte
beides sein aber da drüben ist so ein haus ich würde eher sagen das ist cold war ja das ist
cold war das stimmt das stimmt
also man muss sagen die helis also diese die attack helis waren im bett company 2 fast schon
ein bisschen zu op weil die konntest du nur mit dem tray start richtig erwischen oder mit
einem at4 und gut geflogenen heli hast du kaum mit tray start getroffen und auch kaum mit at4 also
die kleinen helis also die attack helis war fast ein bisschen zu hart in bett company 2 ja mehr
konntest du ja auch nicht spielen auf den maps und es war trotzdem es war trotzdem übelst was los
aber du konntest wenigstens flanken noch weil ich alles voll geschissen war mit gegnern ich
finde die idee was sie erzählt haben 128 gegner irgendwie im neuen battlefield weiß ich nicht ob
das ob ich das so immer kommt kommt aufs game an wie es gemacht ist spielmodus man muss halt sagen
die maps in bett company 2 so massiv waren die gar nicht die waren schlauchig war tapes war tapes
sound preset beste ja bett company 2 sieht heute auch brauchbar aus ja ich meine ich spiele in
kram auch immer auf low details also sprich sogar da sieht es brauchbar aus
ich habe das gefühlt jack frakes macht jedes jahr ein dieses
video immer wieder immer wieder dieses video einmal im jahr
ja da ist was dran
klar aber die gesamte technik hat von 2004 bis 2010 mehr optisch gesehen deutlich größere
sprünge gemacht als von 2010 bis 2020
ja du konntest nicht du konntest ja nicht wirklich vorwärts träfen du konntest ja das
das kommt wahrscheinlich ich denke mal dass das eindeutig an den konsolen ursprüng lag ja aber
ich fand den single wenn man rein den single player anguckt fand ich bett company 1 besser
die bett company 2 story war schon fast zu ernst für bett company also ich persönlich finde bett
company 1 ist tatsächlich die bessere story bessere kampagne für dieses setting bett
company 2 ist aber auch gut ich muss euch ehrlich sagen weder den hardline single player noch den
battlefield 4 single player noch eins habe ich ja nur ein bisschen gespielt fünf war hat auch
hat mir auch nicht gefallen also die die single players die danach haben zwar riesige so show
effekte gehabt im single player so nachdem war es ist geil und sieht das cool aber die
kampagnen haben ja und nicht nicht gefallen ich war noch viel zu wenig bettel viel like das war
eher wie eine gescriptete call of duty kampagne auf historisch so zumal dies damit auch nicht
sonderlich genau genommen haben also das war ich finde bett company 1 kampagne immer noch am
besten vom setting her vom inhalt her das nimmt sich auch nicht wirklich ernst bett
battlefield 3 muss ich sagen ist der single player jetzt der ging aber der hat auch vom
aufbau her finde ich auch nicht sehr gut genau man hat kein extra das finde ich auch gut man
hat kein extra client gebraucht irgendwie um die leute da hinzu zu enden und dann irgendwelche
ungewollten chatnachrichten was auch immer einfach freundesliste den magisch spielen zack einladen
join allerdings hatte das auch ein problem du konntest leuten nicht direkt in das squad nach
join jetzt werden die copypastas ausgebuddelt
also leute die es wirklich ausprobiert haben die fanden es eigentlich fast alle gut ja
es hatte es hatte es war das letzte battlefield was reine server side hit detection gemacht hat
hat den vorteil du wurdest nicht um die ecke erschossen so richtig aber auch bis wenn du
bisschen hinterher gelegt hast aber nicht so extrem dafür hast du selbst teilweise nicht
getroffen obwohl du drauf warst das klingeln war dass das klingeln ist nur von der sniper
eben gewesen das klingeln wenn das irgendwie was eingeblendet hat hier wollte er über zehn
minuten kommen hat er nicht geschafft oder die bett company zwei trailer wobei bett company
zwei hatte den wirklich geilen trailer aber nicht den moment den hier den hier
sebaro klar aber ja ja kenne ich irgendwie ich wollte sogar mal ausprobieren als sie
gesagt haben es gibt jetzt alpha aber habe ich nicht gemacht was mich ein bisschen abgeschreckt
hat ist dass die dass die letzten sechs monaten so viel umgeschreckt haben um umgelegte ich
weiß nicht wie ist wie kommt new world so an auf acht minuten vielleicht hatte deswegen den trailer
dran gemacht nach deswegen hat er den trailer dran gemacht verstehe ja jugendwort des jahres
gucken wir gleich dass das war ein geiler trailer das war ein geiler alter komm pass mal auf ich
zeige euch den youtube hack des jahres easy habt ihr gesehen wie einfach man altersgesperrte
videos sich angucken kann ohne einzuloggen das ist das ist doch mal massiv easy
der war geiler trailer hier
das sind die richt das in die original comrades hier
das war ein geiler trailer
warum der medic auf einmal das soll trifeln weiß man nicht
so die überblendung jetzt finde ich halt so geil warte mal das finde ich halt so geil
dass sie das also über geblendung so nach dem oder das war jetzt die wirklichkeit echte spieler was
ein schwachsinniges echte spieler hätten im leben nicht so dargestanden ich fand das war ein
richtig geiler trailer hat mich ultra gehyped auf das game damals märz 2010 es ist über zehn jahre
ja viel alt man wo ist ich habe gar kein viel alt wo ist mein alt wo alt wo habe ich mein
wo alt im alt leute seht ihr irgendwo wo ist man wo ist mein alt im alt wo ist es ich habe
alt champ nicht da habe ich gerade sein dass ich es nicht hinzugefügt habe ist weg habe ich
irgendwie nicht ist ist nicht vorhanden ja aber hat mich ultra begeistert damals das der trailer
irgendwann gemeint quest design von new world sagt kann ich mir vorstellen weil die haben ja
pvm erst letzten drücker eingebaut so gucken wir uns was gucken wir als nächstes der angebliche
315.000 dollar gaming pc von dr disrespekt eigentlich juckt mich das nicht was dr disrespekt
für ein pc hat die kugel ist das neue elektro art ist jugendwort jugendwort wollten wir uns
angucken genau das schauen wir uns jetzt an copy link zeigt mal her da machen wir mal kurz den
dark reader aus aber man kann abstimmen max beide bei hast du mit mitbekommen dass ich
mein windows server geschrottert habe wollte nach fünf bis sechs monat wieder updates installieren
nee habe ich nicht mitbekommen habe ich nicht habe ich nicht mitbekommen man kann sein windows
server schrotten rein vom updates installieren nicht dass mich das jetzt wundern würde
wundert mich gar nicht das wundert mich das ist es ist es ist immer es ist immerhin noch
hinaus ja ok also jugendwort des jahres was gibt es da
wie alt bist du zwölf was ist ein jugendwort 2020 ok das sind die sachen zur auswahl
schabernack das ist das übelste oldschool wort das hat man 18 120 verwendet warum ist
das jetzt wieder angesagt das ist schabernack das hätte mein uropa sagen können
kommt halt von das konfigen philipp amthor ok
verstehe stehe mittwoch frosch miem meinen pepe miem oder was ist
was zum teufel ist es ist was
ok pains jam das erste bild
also ich bin ja normalerweise was internet memes angeht jetzt auch
nicht der der ahnungsloseste ja
aber ich kenne es nicht
ich kenne es echt nicht keine ahnung sauft
aha das finde ich sogar ganz gut ich kenne das nicht nein ich kenne das nicht
ich ihl ach so ja gut das ist ja auch irgendwelches deutsche deutsche subreddits
lese ich auch nicht deutsche memes kenne ich eh nicht deutsche memes sind meistens
low low brain low brain low low IQ memes damit gebe ich mich nicht ab
deutsche memes das einzige was ich kenne ist der alte junge der aus dem bus aus dem bus raus muss
kenne das wurde wo die bus wo die busschuhe zu geringer sind ich muss raus
das ist das einzige was mir als deutsches meme einfällt ich muss raus
ich mein eigentlich ist es eigentlich sehr fast schon viel sich darüber der hat wahrscheinlich
existenzängste bekommen dass er jetzt nicht aussteigen kann und sonst vor am arsch der
welchen rauskommt eigentlich ist es ja schon fast viel sich darüber lustig zu machen den hier
meine ich ist schon wieder so dumm was ist er mit karsten los ja das ist ja old school das
ist ja old school was ist er mit karsten los das ist aber auch lustig was ist denn bloß mit
nicht mit willi mit willi mit mit karsten los karsten los was ist denn mit karsten los
daily motion 1ks daily motion alter what the hell
so dumm eigentlich ist auch was wo du nicht darüber lachen solltest
wahrscheinlich hat er irgendeine krankheit oder so der läuft ja einfach auf einmal rennt
der hat irgendeine krankheit eigentlich ist gar nicht lustig aber irgendwie finde ich
das ist der bloß mit karsten los okay weiteres jugendort sauftrag das finde also nachdem ich
ja kaum was trinke ist das für mich nicht sinnvoll das war das finde ich aber gar nicht
schlecht wild okay das kenne ich dass das kenne ich was auch angesagt ist dass die leute nicht
sagen es ist schlecht und ich sage es ist schmutz ist zur zeit voll angesagt es ist schmutz schmutz
zu sagen ist gerade wieder voll im trend zumindest bei den bisschen älteren leuten so um die um die
18 19 20 weil das kenne ich von manchen azubis die sagen es ist schmutz zu allem schmutz so was
haben wir noch hier lost ja gut das das aber schon ein paar jahre so no front okay ich kenne
nur homo köfte spießt was das lieblingsessen nach der haftentlassung aha digga ja gut das
ist ja das ist aber auch schon ein paar jahre wobei ich das teilweise wirklich nervig finde
wenn ich mir deutsche teilweise deutsche streams und deutsche youtube videos anguck dass da wirklich
das ist so ein bisschen ich meine wir haben früher bei uns was alter ja alter alter sonst was bei uns
was alter ok aber das hat man zumindest nicht dreimal im satz gesagt digga guck mal hier
digga was der macht digga digga digga man kann es auch übertreiben hat man ich nicht cringe ja
das ist auch nichts neues massala ach nee nicht mass massala ist das ist das hähnchen was ist
mass massala wie auch immer man das ausspricht massala massala spricht man das aus ok ausdruck
für lob kompliment ok alter war früher richtig anstrengend ja aber ich habe es mir auch angewiesen
ich sage das ja heute ich sage ja heute noch teilweise alter was ist das denn ja das ist so
eigentlich bin natürlich ich bin kein roboter sind zwölf datenschutz haben wir auch zur
kenntnis genommen also das beste wort ist cringe und wisst ihr warum es cringe ist ich weiß es
ist das top jugendwort es ist cringe weil cringe das einzig international verwendbare wort davon ist
deswegen
aber was ist das hier ach dass es so köftespieße herkommt
die leute ich weiß nicht bei manchen leuten sprühte sprühte die
gehirnmasse quasi schon fast entgegen alter wenn du die reden hörst nein ich bin kein roboter
zu lowbring content so also cringe ist das beste eindeutig abschicken ehre fürs voten
das wollen sie die wollen halt im trend trendig sein ja ehrenmann
ehrenmann pudermus los ist das beste deutsche miem
so wunderbar mit vor allem
was wurde als beleidigung rausgeworfen haben die nicht letztes oder letztes jahr gab es
nicht haben die nicht vorletztes jahr auch irgendwas entfernt weil das wieder irgendjemand
zu anstößig fand das kommt da war doch das geht doch jedes jahr fast dass irgendwas rausfliegt
weil irgendjemand sich dran stört es ist ja es ist ja mittlerweile tagtäglich über
alle möglichen themen gibt es leute die sich über irgendwas empören und dann kommt dann
einer nein das war nicht so gemeint anscheinend einfach mal zu sagen jetzt neff nicht rum wenn
die sich stört ist ok aber gehen wir nicht auf den sack ich hab die aber auch vor zwei an etwas
rausgeworfen so also was haben wir hier sonst noch schönes das elektro boom video gucken wir
jetzt habe ich noch nicht das habe ich nicht geschaut das neu von dem excellent die gucke
ich immer gern von dem gucke ich fast jedes video zu wild ja wie fandest du die demonstration in
berlin ausgehend von diesem thema habe ich glaube ich am anfang des streams 50 minuten über gott
und die welt gelabert wild ist es ja weil ich habe dazu relativ wenig mitbekommen außer dass
jetzt stattfinden darf ich weiß gar nicht wie viele leute waren jetzt letztendlich da
so mal gucken wie oft er sich wieder schockt in diesem video
was ist
das ist ein meme anguck video das ist natürlich doof die das sind die videos die gucke ich gerade
gerade die kugel nicht wobei das ist eigentlich das ist richtig big brain das finde ich gut
das ist massiv das ist big brain das erinnert mich das erinnert mich aus irgendeiner simpson
episode die dieser was war es der papa guy der immer auf die klaufe die tasse gedrückt hat
der hat wirklich jetzt der hat wirklich unglaublich gute videos wenn es um elektronik
basics geht wo er die sachen erklärt so dass sie wirklich auch kacknubs wie ich kapieren
das ist wirklich das ist wirklich der macht also neben den videos wo er dinger baut die
erklär videos sind wirklich super also zum erklärt das nubs wie ich das verstehen einfach mal was was
ist finde ich dies mit die besten videos wenn man es an dem detail wissen will nicht viel
detail sind da nicht drin zum beispiel das 5g video fand ich auch richtig gut erklärt
elektro boom heißt ja auch mal gucken ob der drunter geschrieben hat der andere
ich habe noch nie probiert was nach kenya zu verschicken
ich meine es läuft nicht unendlich lang aber es ist eine geile idee
ich weiß jetzt schon was passiert er greift dran und kriegt einen schlag das muss auch sein das
geht nicht anders jetzt ich war das war so klar so bright i don't think my capacitor
could handle 120 volt peaks let's just do without the capacitor for now i'm starting to think
they didn't do this test with the 120 volt ac the leds can't take that voltage i can just do
this at low voltage with my function generator so the way it works in the positive cycle the current flows
into this top red led into the side load and returns from this bottom red led and in the negative
cycle it flows into this bottom green led up into the positive side of the load and returns from
this top green led and now we can see the leds blinking i can reduce the frequency so you can see
every cycle and you see in both cycles the output load is powered okay who's next he do be speed
running for his health will my pc work i just simply ac that would have to be dc to ac then
so it would have to be dc to ac then so it would have to be dc to ac then so that it can switch
also das das ach keine elektro zeug habe ich keinen plan oh das ist aber sehr fragwürdig was
er da gebaut hat das ist aber sehr dass das ist monka lebensgefahr alter was er da gebaut hat
wenn der stecker nicht passen wobei das ist nur zwölf volt das nun zwölf volt zwölf volt netz
oder na wobei
was weiß ich nicht
das ist aber eine gute ist das big brain idee ist das da oben esa tan das ist ein optischer
ausgang oder was ist denn das ach nee das ist so ein fertig pc wo man nur so ein kleines kabel
dran steckt aber das ist mutig auf jeden fall das not real do not plug that in it works guys
i don't get it what's wrong here maybe get electrocuted for hundreds time a day he's nervous system please grant me the sweet release of death i like my face
unlustig tells my mom 5g isn't harmful my mom thomas medicine mei die sagt auch dass es in
mir wie mir immer guckt wie das die die kugel meistens nicht die sind meistens irgendwie doof
die anderen videos sind besser wo er sich die ganze zeit mit irgendwas schockt
jetzt was anderes wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt wie man das perfekte winners 10 installiert das
ist bestimmt was wo ich mich wieder lustig machen kann dass so was überhaupt notwendig ist unter
winners das ist oder es ist ein sleeper und wir machen das video zu in this video we're gonna make
okay wir überspringen das intro we're gonna be dealing with all the bloatware that comes with it all
the windows okay auf geht's was hatten der da oben drauf denn ist first getting windows 10 updates
under control was was ist das da irgendwas was man nicht installiert haben will wahrscheinlich so to do this first
we're gonna update windows 10 just go into your settings and go over to update and then we just check
for updates now i've already just i've just done nein da werden wir nie drauf gekommen no need to actually
do it for me and waste your time however once this is done we go into advanced options and there's a
couple things was man hier ausstellen muss ist diese geschichte mit dass man updates mit anderen
schert one we need to change the delivery optimization you got to be very wary of this
ja das also die fall ist nur ein local pc aber ich will generell nicht dass man windows pc updates
verteilt dass das muss man unbedingt ausschalten total beknacktes beknackte setting
fall a lot of times it'll have local pc's and pc's in the internet you're band with to give
windows updates to other people which is super bad so definitely change and tick that off go into
advanced options again and you can also like throttle and do some other stuff i don't really
mess with any of this i just make sure that this this was weg so now that updates is your computers
up-to-date and you not allowing updates from other pc's i like to actually the option is
alt ja mag sein trotzdem muss sie weg locally to do this you can either go into services dot msc
like this oh yeah and with the services pulled up you can go down it's it's coming it's coming
to be lost magic on the windows update and just simply double click stop and then disable the
service warum warum was ist der sinn von windows updates zu zu disable es hat ja schon seinen
i can actually make this come back so the really only way to make sure this happens is to use a third party tool now the one i've been using lately is from sort of actually was ein schwachsinn wozu gefahrt brauche man alles nicht windows update blocker it's down here and you can actually add other du kannst doch auch updates verschieben im zweifelsfall
sie sieht äußerst seriös aus die seite ja also ganz ehrlich so ein scheiß würde ich mir nicht installieren
ich muss noch ich muss noch 2004 abgreifen
excellent excellent name hat das ding schon mal
now with this up i like to protect the service settings and hit apply and that's it i'll go ahead and leave this here and then let's say six months from now there's an update or let's say there's a whoop klingt sehr seriös das ist der windows update blocker whoop was der typ macht windows update deaktivieren ich hab keine ahnung warum
ich weiß nicht ob das perfekte installation ist erst mal das party x ausführen so richtet man mir das perfekt ein
fall wie lange braucht er dafür was nein warum ich führ doch nicht random irgendwelche ok
dann führe ich nach der windows installation irgendwelche skripte von irgendwelchen leuten von github aus die dinger machen wo ich immer weiß was sie machen und die wir gleich gar nicht haben will
ihr das tool macht gut sein aber wahrscheinlich sollte es nicht sollte man es nicht ohne irgendwie ahnung zu haben was es macht laufen lassen
windows 10 die plot klingt auch schon sehr seriös
du vielleicht aber die meisten machen das nicht ich meine jetzt ernst gemeinte frage wofür braucht man genau einen die ploter das einzige was mir einfällt was man die ploten müsste ist die ganze geschichte was an microsoft geschickt wird aber ansonsten
ja candy crush kannst du ja gut meinetwegen aber ansonsten also was willst du groß telemetrie ja das ist das einzige was mir einfällt aber ob jetzt cortana installiert ist oder nicht du musst das macht es jetzt nicht fett 50mb da
tildi das habe ich noch nie eins aus tildi haben wir noch nie tildi jemand sagen können
das die plotet also quasi das gegenteil von dem hier
wie würdest du tildi auf englisch ausspringen tildi weiß ich nicht tildi gucken wir mal lassen wir uns mal vorlesen tildi was tildi
tildi tildi tildi tildi
how to pronounce tildi ok ja ja tildi jetzt haben sie irgendwelche pronunciation guide
tildi was machen die alle 30 sekunden intro für ein wort ok ich sage tildi tildi verstehen die auch auf englisch alles klar
aluminium das stimmt aluminium haben sie irgendwie aluminium haben sie das stimmt das spricht auch jeder anders aus
warum nicht edge ist das einzige das ist das einzige gute für edge da ist pdf viewer aber es kann chrome und firefox auch
die drei klicks mache ich lieber von hand bevor ich custom script von github auf neu installierten windows ausführen
install.net 3.5 i always click yes this because so many applications need.net 3.1 or 3.5
mir fällt keiner ein mir fällt legit keiner ein die.net 3.5 unbedingt noch brauche und wenn kannst du sie immer noch installieren
außerdem funktionieren die meisten 3.5 dinge doch auch rückwärts mit 4.8 wahrscheinlich geht das script nur aber das ist powershell das geht auch so
jetzt fehlt bloß noch rec cc cleaner und wie ist das andere rec oh ne ne ne cc cleaner ist der registry cleaner auch so ein schwachsinnstool
hast du mal das neue chrome edge getestet ja mal aufgemacht sind die daseinsberechtigung nicht verstanden wieder zugemacht
tunup tools genau ja das stimmt
ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich was ich da eingestellt habe typing typing personalization okay aus was hat er da vorher gehabt
general oh was nein nein nein alles weg
ich hab ja schon alles alles aus
ich hab die e-mails schon alle dreißig milliard mal geleakt
ja aber okay also das ist nicht unsinnig das ist nicht unsinnig da hat er schon recht
ja das ist so geil ne das geht ja im neuen windows menü nicht das muss jetzt in die alte systemsteuerung aufgemacht werden
im moment in den hyper warum mein rechner darf sich ruhig runter takten und so das ist vollkommen in ordnung da braucht er weniger strom warum ist das nicht so dass der cpu nicht mehr runter taktet
das ist eigentlich total bescheuert wenn das so ist
die wollen 2010 das control panel kicken jetzt können sie ruhig machen insofern die settings ich meine du kannst ja noch nicht mal du konntest ja noch nicht mal die mouse sensitivity einstellen bis bis zum letzten update über die neue systemsteuerung
die
nicht mehr wenn ich das ausschalte dann geht die suche nicht mehr und außerdem ist das gar nicht so wild weil der initiat erstmal nur neue sachen und sonst im hintergrund man muss sagen das ist ja von microsoft jetzt nicht total durchdacht also das macht schon das macht schon
schon Sinn, dass das an ist. Und gerade auf einer SSD ist es ja nicht so, als bräuchte man jetzt permanent krasse
Disk Performance, oder hätte er da zu wenig?
Windexing?
Ach Quatsch!
Das ist doch überhaupt nichts Schlimmes.
Das ist doch überhaupt nichts Schlimmes. Also das Einzige, wo das man nennenswert loud verursacht ist, wenn du eine Zip Bombe oder irgendwie sowas
entpackst.
Nee, wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen GitHub, wenn du den Linux Kernel als Zip runtergeladen hast
und dann entpackst du den.
Dann mag der Indexer ein bisschen Leistung ziehen, aber ansonsten
Es ist wert, diese Feature zu disablen. Ich empfehle es sehr.
Es gibt mir bessere Leistung.
Es verbessert auch das Leben der Fahrt.
Obviosly die eine Forderung, die zu disablen ist, ist, dass deine Search Funktion ein bisschen mehr gimpft ist. Du kannst es immer noch finden, wie wenn ich XCP suchte.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde, so eine Search Index Geschichte ist fast overrated, wenn man eine SSD hat. Also wenn man gerne nach File Metadaten sucht, Änderungsdatum, sonst was dann ist sinnvoll. Wenn man einfach nur nach Dateinamen sucht, ich finde, es gibt nichts besseres, wie einfach wenn man unter Linux ist und einfach dann find macht.
Weil im Heimatverzeichnis sind meistens jetzt nicht so viele relevante Ordner, wo es ewig dauert. Man muss ja nicht das Find in seinem Repo Ordner mit 30 Milliarden Node Modules ausführen.
Sondern einfach wo man weiß, wo es ist. Zum Beispiel einen Documents Ordner, einen Find machen und gut ist. Oder einen Crep, wenn man nach dem Inhalt sucht. Das geht auf eine SSD unglaublich schnell.
Ganz sicher der Indexer, ok.
Kaufst du dir das neue Black Ops? Wahrscheinlich schon, aber ich warte erstmal ab, wie es ist.
Ja und die Suche geht nicht mehr.
Warum soll ich die Windows Firewall nicht ausmachen? Ich meine die Windows Firewall nicht, dass die großartig daheim im Netzwerk was bringen würde.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass die großartig was macht oder so. Aber die schadet auch überhaupt nichts.
Jetzt komm mal. Also, dass die Windows Firewall jetzt großartig mein CPU belasten wird, das halte ich jetzt mal für ein Gerücht.
Erstmal einen Script von GitHub ausführen und dann die Firewall ausschalten. Ich meine im lokalen Netzwerk kannst du die schon ausschalten, das ist nicht so, als würde die da großartig was machen.
Bis auf ab und zu mal aufplotten, wenn es eine neue Anwendung irgendwo ein Port aufmachen will, das ist aber nicht so sehr im Zweck der Sache. Also das wichtigste daran ist eingehende Verbindungen zu blocken. Das ist im lokalen Netzwerk nicht wirklich wichtig, aber wozu ausschalten? Ich meine das macht doch nichts.
Ja klar, wenn ich sie ausgeschaltet habe, muss ich aber zum Beispiel, warum das auch lokal sinnvoll sein kann. Mal angenommen, man gibt irgendwelche Ordner frei und möchte die einfach mal global blocken oder entblocken. Das ist schon sinnvoll und das ist ja nicht so, als zieht das jetzt großartig CPU.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte man mit Windows Firewall an zum Spielesserver einen 50er Ping und mit Firewall aus einen 30er. Das hat überhaupt keinen Einfluss drauf. Das ist minimal.
Windows Firewall.msc, wf.msc, das würde ich nicht wählen. Inbound rules sind auch die eigentlich wichtigen. Das ist das wofür man den Kram hat. Das andere meinetwegen auch, aber inbound rules ist eigentlich das Interessante daran.
Deswegen braucht man das eigentlich im lokalen Netzwerk auch nicht, weil da kommt eh keiner dran, außer man selbst. Warum schaltet er die nicht einfach aus? Jetzt mal blöd gefragt.
Man kann einfach ausschalten, wenn ich Admin bin. Ich bin hier kein Admin. Man kann die einfach ausschalten.
Also wenn ich eine any any Regel mit allow rein mache, kann ich sie einfach ausschalten? Wo ist das Sinn? Das ist Schwachsensvideo wieder.
Nee, er hat er nicht. Jetzt wird es wild, Alter, wild.
Will es für ausgehende Verbindungen behalten? Okay, ja kann sein. Aber gerade für die Funktionalität. Ich würde eher die Sachen für ausgehende Verbindungen ausschalten, weil da ist es öfters mal nervig.
Wenn irgendwas neu startet, darf dieses System sich an den Port binden oder so.
Okay, das ist irgendwie ziemlich... Ja, okay. Leute, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich es mal riskieren soll heute. Guckt mal, ich muss nämlich noch updaten.
Guck mal, ich hab noch 19.03. Ich hab zwei Major-Updates nicht gemacht. Ich hab 19.10 nicht gemacht und ich hab 20.04 nicht gemacht.
Ob das funktioniert?
Monka Shake? Monka Shake brauchen wir übrigens noch, sehe ich hier gerade.
Monka Shake. Moment, save.
Hallo? Oh, das war jetzt ein hochkritischer Download sehe ich an der Windows. Hätte ich mal Indexing ausgeschaltet. Excellent.
Also, komisches Video. So, was haben wir denn sonst als nächstes noch zu bieten?
Da kann ich ein bisschen... Linux vs. Windows, welches... Oh, das ist mir jetzt zu high IQ Content.
Wie machst du eigentlich deinen Imageport selber? Das ist selber gebastelt.
Quire 1, 8 Monate, Dankeschön. Excellent. Hypersubscriber ja schon fast. Wobei, Hypersubscriber ist mein erster ab 12.
Bist du die Fierce Code Extension schon durch? Nee, ich hab nicht weiter geguckt.
Hat ein Computer gebaut, der aussieht wie ein Gamecube, okay.
Wow, da wird selbst gedrillt hier. Wow, das ist aber... mit CD-Laufwerk. Das ist aber modern.
Moment, also, der hat einen Gaming-PC gebaut, um dann Twilight Princess... Nee, Moment, das ist, äh, doch.
Twilight Princess auf einem Emulator spielen zu können, oder was? Das ist natürlich...
A big brain. Hätte man jetzt einfach auf dem Gamecube spielen können, aber...
Gut, dafür kann er Wii drauf spielen und Switch drauf spielen und CS, aber gut, CS ist ja nichts.
CS spielt der Controller, aber CS läuft ja nur wirklich auf allem.
Was hat er denn da gemacht? Oh!
Schmilzt er mit dem Lötkolben grad das Plastik? Das ist eigentlich ne Idee, auf die Idee bin ich ja noch gar nicht, bin ich ja nie gekommen.
Der, der, der, der benutzt den, den Lötkolben als Plastik-Schneider.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht gut für den Lötkolben.
Und die Abgase sind sicherlich auch nicht so gut. Aber das macht ja nichts, wir sind eh alle 5G-verseucht.
VapeNation erst mal ne Runde. Erst mal ne Runde VapeNation.
Ja, exellent. Das ist genau das, was ich euch letztens versucht hab zu erklären.
Wo ich so ein bisschen, weil ich das noch nie gemacht hab, wo ich so ein bisschen Schiss hatte, dass ich was kaputt mache.
Wo ich Metall durchgeschnitten habe mit dieser Metalltrennscheibe und es so Funken gesprüht hat.
Bis ich dann irgendwann gecheckt habe, ok, das ist normal, wenn man Metall durchschneidet, dass es Funken sprüht.
Ich hab keine Flex, ich hab das exakt so mit so einem Dremel und so einer Scheibe vorne dran gemacht.
Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, Dremel, Dremel.
Das sieht wirklich nicht gut aus.
Ok, das wär fast besser gewesen, das Gehäuse 3D zu drucken.
Ok, das ist aber was, was man sich da nur von außen angucken darf.
Das sieht aus, als wäre da drin ein Sandwich explodiert, ja? Ja, stimmt.
Aluminium.
Ja, das hätte er doch jetzt auch mit seinem Dremel durchschneiden können, da wär das bestimmt glatter gewesen.
Ist das Kleber?
Ich mach, Leute, ich mach nachher ein Windows Update. Mal gucken, ob's crash, ich mach erstmal ein Backup vorher.
Oder aber, das ist eigentlich die optimale, die optimale Situation jetzt, wenn ich Schiss hab, dass mein Windows kaputt geht.
Ich könnte Windows auch einfach neu zählen auf eine 4TB SSD. Ich wollte schon immer eine 4TB SSD.
Was mach ich denn jetzt? Wieso? Weil's geht. Gibt's das schon als NVMe?
Hoho, bisschen teuer. Ein Schnapper, ein wahrer Schnapper.
Gibt's die vielleicht im Angebot irgendwo?
Guck mal. Okay, A-Data. A-Data ist ja auch, was zum Geier ist das? What the fuck?
Was ist denn da drin? Was ist denn da drin?
Okay, Review. Hat keine guten Bewertungen.
Hauptsache, es leucht, aber die ist billiger als die anderen. Die kosten 700 Euro.
Also, was hat die denn für Zellen drin? Von welchem Hersteller ist denn der Flash da drin? Weiß man das? Erkennt man das? Woran sieht man das?
Ich bin mir die ganze Zeit damit beschäftigt. Moin, Kengen. Woran erkennt man was, wer der Hersteller ist?
Weiß man nicht, ne? Ist das Samsung Flash?
Gut, es muss QLC. Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es QLC. Das ist ans Best nicht so billig.
Warum sieht die Seite so komisch aus? Weil es mein Factory ist und ich mein Dark Reader an hab. Oh, jetzt sieht sie besser aus.
Hat keine gute Bewertung. Review. Oh, eine Bewertung nur. Zurzeit alternativlose 4TB mit Schwächen.
Allerdings wird die SSD wirklich... Das werden viele von diesen SSDs, ja.
Eine MB? Was? Ok, das sackt. Ok, wird jetzt nicht mehr viel zu heiß. Wie heiß sollte so eine M2 SSD maximal werden?
Maximal so heiß, dass er anfängt zu drosseln. Ich will nicht nach M suchen. Dass er anfänglich anfängt zu drosseln.
Ich weiß nicht, wann die anfangen. Ok, das sackt. Das ist Müll. Das Ding ist crap. Ganz ehrlich, warum überhaupt eine M2?
Nein, warum nimm ich einfach eine SATA? Macht es doch. Macht es doch, er ist auch nicht fett. Genau. Ja, King Wall ist eigentlich so.
Gerade nicht so was. Ich mein 800... Was ist das? Ich mein ETF 716 Euro. Warum überhaupt für einen Terabyte? Weil man nie genug SSD haben kann. Und irgendwo hin muss die Kohle ja.
Gibt es da ein Review zu? MP5104TB Review. Das ist ziemlich neu, der Kram. Ok, ist... Moment, das ist die kleinere Variante.
Ja ne, also ganz ehrlich, dann hole ich mir lieber eine 4TB EVO. Dann hole ich mir lieber sowas, oder?
Oder vielleicht sogar noch eine Nummer billiger. Hab ich ein bisschen mehr Platz?
Empfehlung für 1TB M2 SSDs. Ich kann dir nur das empfehlen, was ich hab. Ich hab ne ganz normale Samsung. Also ich hab nur 512 aktuell in dem hier.
Und noch ne externe SATA. Also das Teil hab ich aktuell. Und damit kann man sich nicht beschweren. Ich glaube das ist nicht mehr die aktuelle, die würde ich also nicht mehr kaufen jetzt.
Ist dir was ich nicht verstehe? Das gibt ne 960 EVO. Allerdings wenn ich nach EVO SSD so finde ich nur 360 EVO. Wo ist denn da der Sinn? Ach das ist die NVME Variante.
Ach 970 ist jetzt angesagt. Ja, dann würde ich die wahrscheinlich nehmen. Dann würde ich die wahrscheinlich nehmen, ja.
Da kannst du nicht viel verkehrt machen. Guck mal, 5 Sterne bei 5750. Also die würde ich wahrscheinlich nehmen jetzt. Generell ich hatte bisher fast nur Samsung SSDs, sowohl die NVME, also sowohl die M2 als auch die SATA.
Das einzige was ich sonst noch hab sind ein paar billigere Crucial MX. Was ist das hier? Oder was ist MX? 520 SSD oder sowas. Da hab ich noch ein paar, weil die besonders günstig waren. Aber ansonsten hab ich nur Samsung SSDs.
So was kosten die mit 2T? Na guck mal, das ist schon, also ich mein ich krieg für fast den gleichen Preis ne 4TB SATA. Also ich frage wie sich das...
Ja, ok 100 Euro mehr. 100 Euro ist doppelt. Sag mal, warum ist das ne 860 EVO und das andere ne 970 EVO? Sind die 900er Serie, ist die 900er Serie die M2 und die 800er Serie die SATA oder macht das keinen Sinn?
Warum machen die so ne bescheuerte Benahmung? Warum nennen die die nicht einfach alle 970 und 970 SATA und 970 M2? Weil im Prinzip ist da der gleiche Mist da drin.
Na ja, das gibt, Produktbenahmung muss man sich eh fragen, was mit den los ist. Ich mein guck mal so was hier an. MZ77Q4T0BW, alles klar. Es gibt keine M2 mit RGB. Doch, haben wir doch eben gerade gesehen.
Ja, RGB. RGB SSD, exellent. Aber die soll nix taugen. Nein, ich kauf mir nix, ich hab genug da drauf. Warum soll das man? Ich mach jetzt Windows Update und gut ist.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben gerade? Video. Achja, gut, das haben wir fertig. Es gab doch ne M2 mit Display. Woah, echt?
Weil NVMe besser und teurer ist und größere Zahl ist immer. Naja, sobald Samsung, Samsung 4TB, NVMe, sobald die was rausbringen ist am direkt Instant Buy. Aber nur zusammen mit nem neuen PC.
Also sprich, wenn ich mir neuen PC kauf bis dahin, also sprich Ende des Jahres irgendwann, wenn die es mit AMD, wenn es AMD noch schafft oder Anfang nächsten Jahres irgendwann, dann kauf ich mir gleich ne 4TB NVMe dabei.
Wenn es da ne gute gibt. Holst du dir dann einen Threadripper? Nee, ich hol mir dann wahrscheinlich den höchsten Ryzen. Oder ist der? Nee, der 3950X ist noch kein Threadripper, ne?
Das ist der fetteste Ryzen. Der 70 ist ein Threadripper. Der 3950 ist der letzte Ryzen. Den hol ich, also ich hol mir den wahrscheinlich in den 4950X.
Es liegt. And it should have Intel. Ja, das war klar. Also das einzige was Intel aktuell ja noch wirklich zu bieten hat ist, dass sie reine Single oder Low Kern Performance durch höheren Takt in Games.
Das ist das was Intel noch zu bieten hat. Und das einzige was AMD machen muss ist, noch ein paar Prozentpunkte bei ansonsten gleichen Parametern drauf zu packen und Intel sieht in keinem Gebiet mehr noch irgendwie Sonne.
Also da gehe ich fest von aus, dass die nächste AMD Generation Intel komplett chancenlos lassen wird.
AMD is expecting im September. Das ist ja jetzt schon. Okay, was soll das wirklich? Aber da kommen wahrscheinlich erstmal die kleineren, ne?
Da kommen wahrscheinlich erstmal die kleineren. Also bis dann in 4950X rauskommt, dauert wahrscheinlich noch bis Februar. Nvidia macht morgen. Morgen ist Nvidia.
Da bin ich mal gespannt. Vielleicht habe ich ja echt Glück und ich kann mir jetzt endlich nach fast genau drei Jahren wieder einen neuen Rechner kaufen.
Ich halte es nicht mehr aus. Ich will mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen und ich warte ja einfach nur noch auf neue AMD CPUs und neue Nvidia GPUs und dann wird zugeschlagen.
Geld ausgegeben. Das weiß ich nicht, Sky. Keine Ahnung. Ja, da wird es mal wieder Zeit ein bisschen Geld in die Hand zu nehmen und ordentlichen Rechner zu kaufen.
Definitiv keine AMD-GPU, so wie es aktuell aussieht nicht. Das kann sich natürlich ändern, wenn AMD jetzt noch irgendwas ultra krasses GPU-technisch raushaut, dann...
What the fuck? Was macht er mit seiner Grafik? Ich will mir doch einfach nur seinen Rack angucken.
Was für Hardware planst du um die neue CPU herum? Das kann ich dir sagen. Das habe ich nämlich auf Twitter gepostet vor ein paar Tagen und zwar ich kaufe mir einen...
Moment, da. Also wenn ich mir was kaufen würde, kaufe ich mir Folgendes. Hat dich von der Gamescom-Präsentation gerade nichts? Hab ich gar nicht geguckt. Gamescom ist total unbedeutend.
Ja, vielleicht zeigt Blizzard was zum WoW-Addon, aber das juckt mich auch nicht.
So, also was ich mir wahrscheinlich kaufen würde, wäre Folgendes. Wenn es das dann geben... Es ist ein bisschen spekuliert in die Zukunft, weil ob es bis dahin SSDs, 4TB in der Form gibt, weiß ich nicht.
Also was ich mir kaufen würde ist Folgendes. Ich kaufe mir einen Fractal Define 7 Gehäuse, weil ich habe jetzt hier schon einen Fractal... Was sind R4, R5, R6 oder sowas?
Also das würde ich mir kaufen. Invisible PC, ok. Äh, ich glaube ich muss mein Dark Reader ausmachen, sieht kacke aus.
Also das da wird gekauft, das ist ja mehr oder weniger die logische Weiterentwicklung von meinem aktuellen Gehäuse. Ist mein absolutes Lieblingsgehäuse.
Sicher, dass es ein Define 7 sein soll. Warum nicht? Er hat sich was geändert seit den letzten...
Wieso nicht das Gehäuse behalten, weil ich zu faul bin und den alten Rechner eins zu eins daneben stelle als Vorschau, Streaming Vorschau Rechner?
Habe ich jetzt auch so gemacht. Als Rechner mit 2. Monitor ist jetzt mein letzter Rechner, der daneben steht. Ich tausche das dann immer durch einfach.
Also sprich der, ähm...
Das ist der Rechner, den ich da vor, der steht jetzt links als Vorschau, Streaming Vorschau Rechner. Wobei das nicht ganz stimmt mehr, was hier drin ist.
Und jetzt werde ich meinen aktuellen Rechner, der mit dem 8700k werde ich dann rüberschieben als Streaming Vorschau und sonst was Rechner.
Ich tausche das jetzt einfach immer durch und der Rest, ich schmeiße ja sowas ungern weg, der Rest kommt dann auf den Dachboden.
Also das Ding kaufe ich mir, weil ich die letzten 3 PC Generationen auch schon das gleiche Gehäuse hatte. Mehr oder weniger, immer etwas ältere Version.
64G, das muss jetzt sein. Ganz ehrlich, ich hab jetzt, RAM ist gerade so billig und ich hoffe RAM ist dann immer noch billig.
Äh, aktuell sind wir bei 32G RAM. Ohne VMs braucht man natürlich nicht so viel. Aber bei den RAM-Preisen machen wir 64G. Easy.
Muss sein.
64G, eine 4950X, wenn es dann einen gibt. Eine 3080TI, wenn es dann eine gibt, wenn die nicht wieder anders heißen, wir sind ja auch ganz gut da drin ihren Kram mal umzubenennen.
Dann kommt eine 4TB Samsung NVMe SSD rein oder M2 SSD, wenn es die bis dahin gibt. Irgendein Be quiet Netzteil, was passt. Wahrscheinlich das gleiche Be quiet 336 Watt-Dings, was ich jetzt auch hab, bloß die neuere Version.
Ähm, die Netzwerkkarte hab ich schon, da brauch ich nix.
Fetter Noctua-Lüfter, falls es dann einen passenden gibt dafür. Ansonsten mal gucken und dann mal schauen, ja.
Als Case, vielleicht war das iBuyPower, war iBuyPower das CS-Team, nicht das, was Matches manipuliert hat.
Zeit mal.
Es gibt, man muss ja sagen, also Gehäuse mäßig hat sich viel getan in den letzten Jahren, was Gehäuse angeht.
Früher gab es jede Menge große, ekliche Metall-Dinger und mittlerweile gibt es viele stylische, schicke Gehäuse.
Nee, wozu? Die Anordnung ist recht ähnlich. Nee, oben so ein Ding brauch ich nicht.
Oben so was find ich doof, weil ich hab immer viel Zeugs auf meinem Rechner oben drauf stehen, da fällt im Zweifelsverlänger was rein.
Ja, also sowas. Also ich denke mal, dass das um die 3000 Euro ungefähr kosten wird.
Sagen wir mal, CPU 1000, Grafikkarte 1000, wahrscheinlich in Realität ist es eher so, CPU 700, Grafikkarte 1300 wahrscheinlich eher.
Das hier vielleicht 600, 700, wahrscheinlich eher 3500.
Mainboard kommt ja noch dabei, wahrscheinlich eher 3500 so in dem Dreh.
Ganz ehrlich, ich geb für nichts Geld aus, ich kauf mir alle drei Jahre einen ordentlichen Rechner und gut ist.
Magst du keine Wasserkühlung? Nö. Ich bin irgendwie kein Wasserkühlungsfan.
Noch mehr, ja mal gucken, wenn es soweit ist.
Ich geb dir auch 4K für aus, mehr muss nicht sein, aber dann hab ich wenigstens was ordentliches wieder für die nächsten drei Jahre.
Ich mein, man muss sich mal überlegen, ich hab's jetzt schon total auf dem Stream gesagt.
Wie sehen eigentlich die Noctua für Ryzen aktuell so aus?
Ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt, also das hätte es früher, dass man drei Jahre lang einen PC benutzt und der immer noch top, oberes Ende ist, hätte es nicht gegeben.
Ich mein, 8700K, 1080Ti, das ist drei Jahre später immer noch absolut top.
Das ist jetzt nicht ultra high end, aber gehört bestimmt zu den top 5% der Systeme noch.
Nach drei Jahren, das ist doch lächerlich.
Fans. Ok, was braucht man für einen AMD, nee Moment, nicht Fans, CPU cooler.
Für, den hab ich glaube ich gerade, nee Moment, den hab ich glaube ich gerade, was hab ich denn gerade für Lüfter?
Den oder, ich glaube ich hab einen, ich hab einen, ja den da, den da hab ich gerade.
Kann man den auch für ein Ryzen nehmen? Ok, muss man, Produkt, kann man das filtern?
Ah hier, Compatibility bei CPU, AMD, AMD 4.
Moment, woher weiß ich jetzt, woher weiß ich jetzt, ich check's nicht, woher weiß ich jetzt welcher, welcher CPU, passen die alle auf alles oder wie?
Achso, passen alle auf, ist ja auch klar, ich mein es ist im Endeffekt einfach nen, nen, nen, nen, nen, nen, nen, nen, kühler, ja, also dann, wenn das Mounting passt, CPU Compatibility.
Ah ja, ja wunderbar, da kauf ich mir doch wieder den oder, also mit dem bin ich super, super zufrieden gewesen.
Oder gibt's noch was besseres?
Oh, vielleicht hol ich mir auch die Black Version, weil die normale Noctua Version ist, ich hab noch so, noch so Aufsätze dafür für die, für den CPU Kühler, lustigerweise das einzige was ich gemoddert habe ist der CPU Kühler, so doof es klingt.
Ähm, ja, ich hab noch so Chromax Aufsätze, warte mal, richtig, richtig dumm eigentlich, hier, solche Aufsätze hab ich noch für den Kühler, total sinnlos, also bringt angeblich eher Flow und sonst was und ehrlich gesagt realistisch, realistisch betrachtet bringt es nichts.
Warum ich nicht den alten verwende? Naja, weil der alte noch auf der alten CPU drauf bleibt, damit der Rechner weiter funktioniert.
Ja, so, also irgendwie sowas werd ich mir dann wahrscheinlich holen, mit einem ein Kühler reicht, man kann auch noch einen zweiten, also wer ganz hart drauf ist kann zwei Kühler dran machen, zwei Lüfter dran machen, da ein und da ein, aber das braucht man nicht.
Wie warm ist deiner Eidl? Ähm, Moment, sieht man das mittlerweile nicht im Task Manager? Nee.
Was ist die einfachste Variante rauszukriegen, wie warm die CPU ist? Intel, hier, Intel Tools. Wobei haben wir nicht mal was dafür programmiert, was das macht?
Jaja, hiermit sieht man auch die Temperatur, äh, äh, 47, 46, irgendwie so.
Wechselst du auch die Wärmeleitpaste beim CPU Kühler? Ähm, nein. Ich trau mich da auch nicht mehr dran, weil ich hab meine, mein 8700K ja geköpft und ich trau mich nicht mehr dran den abzumachen.
Ich hab den geköpft und den Heatspreader mit flüssig Metall wieder dran gemacht und dann den Lüfter drauf gedrückt und fest zugeschraubt und nie wieder angefasst.
Da trau ich mich nicht mehr dran, das bleibt so, das bleibt für immer so. Nee, ähm, aber ich verwende die, ich glaub, ist das nicht sogar die, die der Bauerwärmeleitpaste? Ähm, Thermal, Grizzly, äh, das da? Ist das nicht sogar die Bauerwärmeleitpaste?
Nee, das ist was anderes. Nee, Conductor Naut ist die Flüssigmetall, die Wärmeleitpaste zwischen Heatspreader und Kühler.
Ja, die hab ich drauf, genau. Wärmeleitpaste ist übrigens eines, der auf Grammpreise oder Milliliterpreise berechnet, eines der teuersten Produkte überhaupt.
Komm mal, es ist nämlich 1,5 Milliliter für 17,30. Ja, das ist teurer als Drucker-Tinte. 1,5 Milliliter 17 Euro.
Wobei, nee, nee, nee, okay. Hier gibt's das AliExpress, ob das original ist? Guck mal, AliExpress kostet das dann nur 3,30. Das ist bestimmt nachgemacht, das ist wahrscheinlich was ganz anderes drinne dann.
Also, sagen wir mal 9 Euro, sagen wir mal 10 Euro ungefähr für 1 Milliliter. Boah, über, guck mal was. 1.000 Milliliter sind 1 Liter, ne?
Also sprich, kostet das dann 10.000 Euro der Liter? Seh ich das richtig? Der Liter kostet ungefähr 10.000 Euro? Das ist ja exzellent.
Ein Schnapper. Ja, also das ist der Rechner, den ich mir kaufen werde dann. So machen wir das. Ende des Jahres oder Anfang nächsten Jahres, je nachdem wann da AMD und Nvidia mitspielt.
Müssen wir mal gucken. Ich bin ja skeptisch, dass sie das noch schaffen bis zum Ende des Jahres. Ich mein, ich war einer der ersten in Deutschland, der dann 8.700k hatte. Ich hatte Ultraklück. Also, der Bauer und Konsorten, die hatten garantiert noch früher ein, die kriegen ja immer direkt vom Hersteller ein.
Ich hab einfach bei 3 Shops vorbestellt, quasi schon bei der Ankündigung. Und das war die, wo du 3 Monate Wartezeit auf den 8.700k hattest. Und irgendein Shop in Berlin hat dann geschickt.
Und ich hab den anderen, den ich dann 2 Wochen später auch noch gekriegt, hab ich dann irgendwie wieder zurückgeschickt. Und den anderen hab ich abgestellt. So, und ich hab mir damals überlegt, ob ich die Shops scammen sollte. Hab ich aber nicht gemacht.
Also sprich, also nicht scammen. Scammen in Form von, ich bau den ein, guck wie viel er schafft an Overclocking und schick dann den zurück, der sich am schlechtesten overclocken lässt. Hab ich aber nicht gemacht, weil die waren eh nicht lieferbar, deswegen ich hab eh nur einen bekommen.
Und dann hab ich, ne ne machste nicht, das ist ja auch fies, sowas sollte man auch nicht machen. Und zumindest hab ich echt geschwitzt beim Köpfen von dem 8.700k, weil ich hätte in den nächsten 2-3 Monate keine Ersatz-CPU bekommen, hätte ich den geschrottet.
Also wer sich fragt, wie sowas aussieht. Ja hier sieht man es ganz gut. Ja ich hab nicht das Bauer-Köpf-Kit verwendet, sondern irgendein anderes, weil das nicht lieferbar war.
Jaja, genau das hier, oh da hab ich geschwitzt. Man schiebt die CPU da rein, Doktor Delid hab ich gemacht. Man schiebt die CPU da rein. Aber man muss hören wie es knackt.
Wenn man hört wie es knackt, das ist, also generell mechanisches Knacken aus einer CPU zu hören, ist gewöhnungsbedürftig. Na ja, so schlimm ist das jetzt auch nicht. Pass mal auf jetzt knackt es.
Dann macht es einen Klack und gleich haben wir es geschafft. Also wirklich Knacken aus der CPU ist eine Sache, die waren nicht verlötet, dann kannst du das nicht machen.
Die waren mit Wärmeleitpasta draufgeklebt. So, da macht man oben den Heat-Spreader ab. Dann macht man den Heat-Spreader von der CPU ab.
Dann nimmt man irgendwie, der Bauer macht das immer mit einer Rasierklinge. Das hab ich mich nicht getraut mit einer Rasierklinge zu machen. Man putzt das ab. Ich hab das mit ein bisschen Alkohol und einem Plastikstück Kreditkarte gemacht.
Dann kratzt man das ab, den ganzen Müll. Genau. Oh, das da oben kann man mit einem Teppichmesser machen, aber auf der CPU mit einem Teppichmesser ist halt, ja. Ich hätte es, ohne Scheiß, ich hätte es damals auch mit den Fingern machen sollen. Auf die Idee bin ich nicht gekommen.
Also man kratzt den Silikon. Den Silikon misst runter. Man muss das runterkratzen, weil ansonsten passt das nicht mehr richtig drauf danach. Wozu das Ganze? Dass die Wärmeleitung zwischen dem Heat-Spreader und der CPU-Core größer ist.
Und das macht massiv was aus. 15 Grad teilweise, ja. Also ich hatte den, ich hab den übertaktet auf 5,1 Gigahertz. Also 5 bis 5,2 hatte ich immer mal ausprobiert und 5,1 war ein Stable.
Aber halt ordentlich mehr V-Core drauf. Den hatte ich übertaktet und der ging, das ging halt nicht richtig mit die Fault-Wärmeleitpaste, ja. Der war immer permanent am Limit, was Temperatur, also 105 Grad.
So und danach hab ich die CPU geköpft und flüssig Metall dazwischen geschmiert. Also man macht hier so eine Metalllegierung drauf und hier und dann klebt man das wieder zusammen.
Weil normalerweise ist zwischen dem hier und dem Heat-Spreader nur Wärmeleitpaste und die ganz krassen Leute lassen den Heat-Spreader weg, ja. Und dann klebt man das wieder drauf.
Und das hat 10-15 Grad Unterschied. Also jetzt hab ich unter Prime 95 Volllast, kein 105 Grad und Trottel mehr.
Sondern, keine Ahnung, 95 oder so, wenn es volle Pulle übertaktet, hoher V-Core ist. Aber ich hab übrigens wieder runtergetaktet.
Ich bin aber auch ein Kacknub, ich glaub ich hab runtergetaktet, aber den V-Core oben gelassen.
Aber muss ich doch mal gucken, läuft das Intel-Tool noch? Steht da, steht da die...
Sieht man die CPU-Spannung irgendwo?
Sieht man da irgendwie die CPU-Spannung?
Hab ich doch wieder runtergestellt, ja.
Nee. Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich seh es jetzt nicht. Das Tool sah doch auch mal irgendwie anders aus.
Ah, hier, nee. Man konnte doch bei dem Tool viel mehr umstellen.
Was auch immer. Wurscht. Ich schaff zumindest 5,1 Gigahertz unter dem Temperaturlimit zu bleiben, auch mit Prime 95, wenn es ne Weile läuft.
Und das ging erst, seitdem ich den Kram geköpft hab und Flüssigmetall dazwischen gemacht hab.
So, da zeigt das hier noch irgendwie genau. Jetzt machst du hier, machst du hier das drauf. Genau, sprayste drauf.
Sprayste drauf, da machst du da noch ein bisschen drauf und dann klebst du wieder zusammen.
Äh, Köpfen lohnt sich aktuell gar nicht, weil die CPUs mittlerweile verlötet sind.
Ja, aufhaut drauf. Genau. Und dann ist hier so ne Kohle beschichtet oder was das ist.
Äh, Wattelstäbchen dabei, da kann man das verteilen. Man muss da echt nicht viel drauf machen, ne. Ein bisschen, ein bisschen reicht.
Das ist so ne, so ne Metalllegierung. Man kann da nach oben auf den Heatspröler ein bisschen was drauf machen, wenn man will, muss man aber nicht.
Ähm, und dann macht man das wieder drauf. Und gut ist.
Man muss aufpassen, dass das nirgendwo drauf kommt. Mit Uhu! Nee, das hab ich nicht gemacht.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ich meinen CPU-Kühler nicht abmachen will, weil ich hab's nicht wieder festgeklebt.
Ich hab's einfach drauf gemacht, CPU-Kühler festgepresst und gut ist.
Mal noch Kontakt mit dem Friseur gehabt, klar.
Ja, ja, da hab ich echt geschwitzt bei.
Exzellent.
315.000 Dollar, der Dr. Disrespect, das wird jetzt aussehen.
Don't learn to program in 2020.
Also den Typ müssen wir nicht weiter gucken, glaub ich, oder?
What the f...
Der geht mit hartem, hartem Gerät an sein Gehäuse ran, der Typ.
Hätte er auch mit seinem Tremel durchdrehmeln können.
Kennst du Traffic und hast ne Meinung zu, dazu kann ich dir nur folgendes empfehlen.
Archiv.
Geht das Archiv eigentlich mittlerweile?
Ist immer noch nicht kaputt.
Er ist immer noch kaputt.
Also das neue Archiv, das alte Archiv geht immer noch.
Archiv.
Programmiert er da eigentlich noch dran rum am Archiv, oder ist das...
Das RIP.
So.
Weil ich hab zum Thema Traffic und Linux erst, glaub, letzten Monat...
Oh nee.
Kann man das...
Das da.
Ja.
Gemacht.
Im Stream.
Der Start ist schon wieder geil.
Und das haben wir gemacht über Cloudflare und Docker und Traffic.
Haben wir das gemacht.
Also gerade in Kombination mit Containergeschichten ist Traffic gut.
Einzel würde ich es nicht verwenden.
Einzel ist die Config zu Cancer.
Weil die Traffic Config, also gerade die, die man von Hand schreiben muss, die ist nicht schön.
Da würde ich was anderes verwenden.
Also Reverse-Proxy ohne Docker-Gedöns.
Entweder nimmt man den Klassiker Engine X.
Oder man nimmt Kaddi oder sowas, wenn es eine einfache Config haben soll.
Engine X ist halt ein bisschen komplizierter zu konfigurieren.
Kannst aber alles mögliche hiermit machen.
Apache nehme ich gar nicht mehr für nix.
Ich hab seit, außer auf der Arbeit ab und zu mal...
Bitte Link hier rein.
Oh.
So.
Hier.
Es gibt jetzt angeblich so einen Antworten-Feature auf Twitch.
Aber irgendwie gibt es das hier nicht mehr.
Hier.
Das da.
So.
Das ist echt ein Gehäuse.
Das kannst du dir nur von außen gut angucken.
Du hast heute von KeckW geträumt.
Ich träume öfters von Twitch-Emotes.
Ich hab letztens, ich wollte es noch auf Twitch schreiben, aber ich hab es dann...
Ich hab letztens auch wieder was total Wirres mit Twitch-Emotes geträumt.
Ich weiß es aber schon gar nicht mehr.
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Also...
Ich glaube, es wäre besser gewesen, der hätte sich das Gehäuse 3D gedruckt.
Und ich glaube, so ein Gamecube-Gehäuse könnte man sich wahrscheinlich sogar relativ gut 3D drucken.
Was hat denn das für eine Abmaße in so einem Gamecube-Gehäuse?
Hier.
15, 15, das geht.
Wie viel kann man hier drucken?
Also wie viel könnte ich mit meinem 3D-Drucker drucken?
Abmaße, Abmaße.
Hier.
Ohne Probleme, easy.
Ich könnte ein Gamecube-Gehäuse drucken.
Ich hab 21 mal 20 und das Gamecube-Gehäuse ist 11 mal 15 mal 16.
Easy.
Ich glaube, es wäre für ihn fast besser gewesen, anstatt diese Sache hier zu bauen.
Er hätte sich wirklich ein Gehäuse 3D gedruckt.
Das dauert zwar, aber das hat auch gedauert.
Ne, los geht wozu?
Ich brauch ja kein Gamecube.
Ich guck mal, ob es ein Gamecube-Gehäuse-Nachbau gibt.
Gibt's bestimmt.
Gamecube-Case.
Mich wundern, wenn's das nicht gibt.
Ja.
Lul.
Guck.
Ah, Moment.
In klein.
Ja, gut.
Das kannst du ja dann ein bisschen größer machen.
Guck, es gibt fertige Gamecube-Gehäuse, schon fertig gemacht, zum Ausdrucken.
Ja, er hätte mich auch echt gewundert, wenn nicht.
Und er könnte das sogar in blau drucken, und da wär's in blau quasi wie in echt.
Nur halt nicht von Nintendo.
Ja, ich glaube, das wäre die bessere Wahl hierfür gewesen.
Weil dann hätte er nicht rumdrehmeln müssen und hätte gleich passend gehabt.
Ja.
Ja, Overwatch, please.
Geh mal weg.
Nee.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Video kacke.
Wahrscheinlich geht's eine Minute um dieses Thema und danach um alles andere.
Aber wir haben jetzt mal eine andere Folge.
Wir schauen mal.
Oder Zigarettenrauch!
R g b ist ein Muss, also los.
Und kauft es wohl kommen zur letzten Folge bevor wir ein und beide Tage machen.
Das liegt an der Erinnerung, der Name hat mir bis vor kurzem gar nicht so viel gesagt.
Hat ihr mal geschaut, wie viele Zuschauer Dr Disrespect auf YouTube den letzten Stream
Ich würde mal interessieren, wie, wie, wie sehr sich das hält.
Das? Wusstet ihr, dass der Call of Duty Community Manager war?
Zu, äh, MW3? Nee, äh, zu Black Ops 2?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
MW3?
Ja, und hat ein paar Maps gebastelt.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich so, dass, dass, dass, äh, äh, übertrieben teure Alienware-Zeug da...
Nee, warum er gebannt wurde, wusste man nicht.
Das, ja, unrealistisch.
Also, wie gesagt, mein PC, also das, was ich ja gerade gezeigt hab, was ich mir dann zusammenbauen will, wenn es die neuen gibt, das kostet, was weiß ich, wenn es hochkommt, sagen wir mal 4K, wenn es hochkommt, ja.
Ähm, wie, wie kommt man auf 315.000?
Sind das denn da Goldbarren zum Beschweren unten drinnen oder so?
Diamantknöpfe?
Ja, was du grad, was du grad für Gaming gar nicht, gar nicht notwendig ist, wahrscheinlich sogar schlechter, wahrscheinlich ist es für Gaming besser, man nimmt einen mit weniger Kern und höherem Takt als den da.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwo eine Software gibt, die 64 Kerne und 128 Threads wirklich effektiv nutzen kann, aber, ja, es ist so ein bisschen natürlich auch der Flex dabei.
Ja, natürlich, ja, aber selbst damit kommste net auch so ein...
... was man genau für diese Plattform nehmen kann, auch verbaut, und zwar das Asus ROG Zenith 2 Extreme Alpha, ich hab ja das Zenith X...
Der Main-Bot-Name, Alter!
Asus Republic of Gamers Zenith 2 Extreme Alpha, da fehlt eigentlich noch das obligatorische Fatality Killer Headshot Pro oder sowas dahinter.
Obwohl die Fatality ist ja mittlerweile bei S-Rock, glaube ich.
Okay, was, was haben wir denn da so, haben wir da irgendwas, was ist... also, mal haben, zweimal Wi-Fi 6, okay, paarmal USB 3 mit Charge, ein 10G-Port, äh, nen...
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen den Ports, die rot sind und den Ports, die rot-rot-blau sind?
Lasst mich raten, das ist USB 3.2 Generation 2, äh, 3, ach du Scheiße, USB 3.2 Gen 2 ist das, und das ist, äh, USB 3.2, nein, nein, nein, das ist USB 3.2 Gen 1, und das ist USB 3.2 Gen 2, und das ist USB 3.2, zweimal 2.
Das wird's sein, oder?
So, das ist ein USB-C-Stecker.
Die USB-Vernahmung ist einfach so für'n Arsch.
Okay, das gibt dann hier nochmal 10G, und das ist bestimmt auch 10G, aber ohne dass 10G dransteht.
Die Farbbedingung, was ist das da oben für Knöpfe? BIOS Reset, okay, Clear, irgendwelche Audio-Ausgänge, unten Optik, okay, relativ Standard, ganz ehrlich, ich hab jetzt auch einen Main-Mod mit 10Gb-Karte, weil das nicht viel teurer war, aber im nächsten Rechner werde ich das nicht mehr machen.
Das ist komplett sinnlos, ich hab genug 10Gb-Karten für PizziExpress, und PizziExpress ist fast alles leer. Wer braucht so viel USB? Ja, haben. Brauchen, brauchen, wehen, na ja, sagen wir, brauchen nicht wirklich.
Also, ich hab jetzt hier drinnen, zeigt mal hier, Tastatur, Micro-Controller zum Programmieren, USB, hier Sound für Mikrofon, die Elgato-Karte, eine externe Platte, was ist das hier? Ich weiß gar nicht, was das hier ist, warte mal, was ist das hier? Wo geht das hin?
Tastatur, Maus, also ich, sag mal, ich hab jetzt so, ich hab 8 USB-Dinger belegt ungefähr, also gar so unsinnig ist es nicht, wobei 4 da von vorn am Gehäuse belegt sind.
Wir haben Kühlung auf den VRM, das kann man sich schon gar nicht mehr vorstellen, und so unglaublich viele Anschlüsse, das ist der Wahnsinn. Bei den Grafikkarten, ja, um das Büdli natürlich auch zu füllen, braucht man nicht eine. Wobei es heißt nicht mehr SLI, wie heißt das jetzt nochmal? SLI ist ja out, das heißt jetzt ja irgendwie, was, Crosslink oder so?
Mehrere Karten, in diesem Fall sind es 2 Grafikkarten, und zwar 2x.
N-V-Link, N-V-Link, das heißt SLI ist ja out.
Ja, also SLI, selbst geschenkt würde ich es natürlich nehmen, aber ich finde SLI in der heutigen Zeit irgendwie doof. Seit es SLI gibt, macht es mehr Probleme als ohne SLI, klar, es hat mehr Performance, aber was Mikro, Rokla und Zusammenspiel angeht, fährt man einfach bequemer ohne SLI.
Steht da ein PC auf dem Tisch? Nee, nebendran.
Wie viel RAM ist das? 256G? Ja, aber trotzdem, was wollen die machen?
Also, du kannst hier die krasseste Hardware der krassesten Hardware kaufen und über 10K kommst du halt schwierig.
Es sei denn, du kaufst ja halt irgendwelche Server-Dinger mit 4 CPUs und so, was auch immer, aber sonst nicht.
Wie? Nur? Nur? Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass der die 4TB RGB SSD hätte.
Dass noch 14 Corsair ML-AGB-Lüfter verbaut sind, gibt es jetzt gar nicht so viel Infos über den Rechner.
Das bedeutet, wir wissen gar nicht, was für ein Netzteil verbaut ist. Ich vermute natürlich ein höherwertiges Netzteil, sowas wie ein Corsair HX1200 mit 80 plus Platinum-Zertifizierung für um die 200 Euro.
Das kann man bei so einem PC machen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz kommen wir hier mit diesen ganzen leistungstragenden Komponenten auf einen Endpreis von circa 9000 Euro.
Bisschen wenig im Vergleich zu 3500 Dollar. Vielleicht haben sie wirklich irgendwelche Goldbachen drinne.
Der PC ist natürlich custom-wassergekühlt. Dafür kennt man Digital Storm und dieser PC hat auch das Digital Storm Custom Gehäuse, bei dem ich gar keine Ahnung habe, was das überhaupt kosten kann.
Nichtsdestotrotz werden diese Komponenten bei weitem nicht 10.000 Euro überschreiten. Das bedeutet, wir sind hier maximal bei einem Preis von 20.000 Euro. Und daher frage ich mich, ist dieser Titel mit 315.000 Dollar-PC nicht ein bisschen clickbaitig?
Natürlich! Natürlich! Was sonst?
Das ist definitiv kein 315.000 Dollar-PC. Was meint ihr dazu? Habt ihr mehr Infos?
Was machen die Lüfter da?
Also von wo ziehen die Lüfter denn bitte schön Luft an? Hier ist eine Platte drüber normalerweise.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Also egal in welche Richtung die pusten. Also raus pusten können sie nicht. Hier ist eine Platte drüber.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Wie? Das war's jetzt?
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt noch der Clou, warum das 315.000 Euro kostet.
Ja dann ist ja... Ich sag doch, Video wo es 2 Minuten umgeht, der Rest ist was anderes. Oh ja, das brauchen wir jetzt. Das muss jetzt sein.
Das muss mal zwischendurch.
Du, du.
Ok, genug. Weiter.
Aber Maus, das muss die aushalten. Das ist immerhin eine... Da steht Pro drauf auf der Maus. Wenn da Pro, Pro, nicht Bro. Das ist ja kein Bro. Das ist eine Pro. Wo Pro drauf steht, muss auch Pro drin sein.
Wie wir ja alle wissen. Jeder der sagt, er ist Pro, ist natürlich auch Pro.
Oh, was gucken wir als nächstes? Oh, das ist mir zu hart gekostet jetzt.
What's in my home network? Ja, da kann ich ein bisschen über andere Netzwerk Setups lästern. Das ist gut.
Was ist im Home Network? Ok, schonmal eine APC, USB. Ok, ok, ok. Schlechte Belichtung ist drinne.
Äußerst, äußerst schlechte, schlechte Belichtung ist da unter seinem Schreibtisch.
So, bin wieder da.
Ist das ein Mikrotik? Das ist ein Mikrotik-Switch?
Exzellent. Der weiß, was er macht.
Äh, meine Maus gestern Geisshoff gegeben, Empfehlung. Also ich hab jetzt seit ungefähr zwei Monaten oder so, hab ich die Kombination aus ähm...
Aus der Maus und dem Auflade-Pad. Wobei, war das Auflade-Pad dabei?
Ich bin mir jetzt ja mit einer Schock-Verwerbung gemacht, da kann das ja nur was sein.
Äh, ne, das Auflade-Pad ist glaub... War das das hier?
Leute, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich mir da gekauft hab. Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz nachgucken, ich sag's euch gleich.
Mein Prime, meine Bestellung, Logitech.
Logitech. Hier, Pro, die da, die Maus und G-Powerplay. Und das da.
Also das, die Kombi hab ich grad am Laufen. Die Kombi hab ich grad am Laufen.
So ein bisschen kleiner mache. Also sprich, die Maus mit dem Maus-Pad.
Das schöne, das ist kein... Also für CS-Leute ist das... Also für die, die 3 Meter 360-Radius haben, ist das nichts.
Weil das Maus-Pad ist nur 30 mal 30. Das reicht für ein Meter halbe Drehung CS-Go-Leute nicht.
Ähm, wenn man ein bisschen was anderes spielt, wo man jetzt nicht nur die Ultra-Ultra-Law-Sense hat, reicht das.
Ja, und das Gute in Kombination ist, dass halt das Maus-Pad die Maus auflädt.
Das heißt, ich muss nie wieder Maus laden. Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Und man muss auch... Also man kann die Maus natürlich auch ohne dieses Maus-Pad verwenden, es ist ein Empfänger dran.
Aber in dem Maus-Pad ist halt ein Empfänger für die Maus dran und man... Also man verbindet im Prinzip...
Man kann drei Maus-Pads nebeneinander stellen. Das könnte man machen.
Das ist tatsächlich... Also wirklich schon sehr, sehr big brain, der Vorschlag. Kann man machen, ja.
So, und... Also du hast einen Empfänger für die Maus drin und das Maus-Pad lädt die Maus.
Das ist äußerst nice, ja. Sehr, sehr nice. Ist das.
Und ich muss sagen, ich merke auch keine Verzögerung und eine Wireless-Maus ist wirklich...
Ich hab's bis vor drei Monaten selbst gesagt, finde ich unsinnig, ist sehr angenehm.
Dafür ein Kabel vom Maus-Pad, naja logisch. Wenn das Maus-Pad die Maus auflädt, braucht das ja Strom.
Wie soll das Maus-Pad wireless die Maus laden und selbst wireless sein?
Mit eigenem... Mit Laser.
Vielleicht, wenn man einen Gaming-Tisch hat. Da hat er sich einen guten Switch ausgesucht.
Der ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Garage.
Ja, also MikroTik ist preisgleichlich wirklich top. Geh weiter jetzt.
Juckt mich nicht. Was hat er da? Ein Wreck.
Und erstmal, erstmal... Wie hieß das? Das, mein Jugendwort?
Sauftrag oder so, ne? Macht der jetzt? Nein.
Ich will mir die Wörter angucken. Ich glaub Sauftrag hieß es.
Okay, zeig her. Lass mal den MikroTik-Switch.
Was ist das in CRS 3? Der ist gut, der ist gut. Das sind die mit 4-Port, 4-Port 10G.
Das ist nichts größeres davon. Ja, aber die kann man echt empfehlen. Top, Top-Dinger.
Wann kannst du ein Tutorial über MikroTik und VLAN machen? Ich verstehe die Einrichtung nicht.
Oh, das ist schwierig, weil da bräuchte ich erstmal Hardware, mit der ich das zeigen könnte gescheit.
Na, ich hab noch einen. Ich hab ja noch einen 5-Port, 4-Port 10G-Switch hier.
Das könnten wir mal machen. Das schreib ich mir gleich.
Gucken wir mal hier. Stream-Ideen. MikroTik-VLAN-Einrichtungen.
Das können wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken. Da nehmen wir einen günstigen Switch, der sich auch lohnt.
Und ja, ich geb dir recht, es ist unnötig kompliziert.
Nee, das war letztes Jahr, Retag. Das war unnötig kompliziert.
Normalerweise ist VLAN-Einrichtung gerade auf, also wenn man jetzt nicht Inter-VLAN-Rooting einrichten will,
aber rein Switch-Config VLAN ist normalerweise total easy.
Du kannst zwei Sachen einstellen. Du stellst entweder ein, der Switch soll in den VLAN rein,
also quasi deteckt automatisch alle reinkommenden Tracks.
Mit einem speziellen VLAN-Tag und entfernt das VLAN-Tag wieder beim ausgehenden Traffic oder hat vielleicht einen Default-VLAN.
Also die zwei Sachen kannst du einstellen. Oder es ist ein Port, wo mehrere VLANs erlaubt sind.
Und das kannst du in der GUI normalerweise schön einstellen.
Allerdings, MikroTik macht es unnötig kompliziert, die VLAN-Config. Das ist wirklich total beknackt.
HJ2510, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön für den Sub.
HiIQ-Subscription. Du hast das mit MikroTik wieder sein gelassen, war mir doch zu schwer.
Das ist ein bisschen Gewöhnungsbild. Gerade VLAN-Config ist wirklich unnötig kompliziert.
Ich habe die Vermutung, ich habe es aber selbst noch nicht gemacht.
Das können wir dann mal sogar im Stream ausprobieren.
Die VLAN-Config über CLI ist wahrscheinlich sogar einfacher als über das Web-Interface.
Moin, Cortana, LX, IX. Excellent.
Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Ich habe das noch nie über CLI gemacht.
Ja gut, wie gesagt, da muss man sich nicht drüber anhören. Das habe ich ja schon selbst auf das gesagt.
Was hat er? Oh, hat er eine Konsole da drin? Hat er wirklich eine Konsole?
Und was ist das?
Also lohnt es sich überhaupt nicht zu kaufen. Viel zu teuer und viel zu unsinnig.
Aber manchmal hat man Glück und es gibt auf eBay alte, alte Konsolen.
Dann kann man es aus Just For Fun mal machen.
Ja, sowas, sowas. Also neu ist absolut unsinnigste Investition überhaupt.
Aber gebraucht kann man das mal machen. Das ist eigentlich ganz witzig.
Nicht, dass man es in irgendeiner Art und Weise brauchen würde, aber man kann einfach hin, hin.
Warum ist es jetzt gelb?
Warum ist der Titel jetzt gelb? Welcher Hackermann war hier wieder am Werk?
Daniel Lull, 14 Monate. Oh, 14 Monate. Das ist ja schon Hypersubscription.
Okay, wir refreschen die Seite mal. Und jetzt ist es nicht mehr gelb.
Oder liegt es am Dark Reader?
Nö, keine Ahnung.
Moment, ich wollte die Konsolen mal sehen.
Das war Daniel Lull, alles klar. Habe ich schon fast vermutet.
Wie gesagt, total unsinnig, aber cool. Also wenn man es günstig kriegt auf eBay, kann man das mal.
Also was ich euch eher empfehlen würde, ein Schatzenkonsol, das ich euch empfehle,
es gibt manchmal günstige...
Wie heißen die Dinger eigentlich?
KVM, IP KVM Dinger.
Also sprich, ein Gerät, was du an den Rechner steckst, an die Grafikkarte steckst und an USB steckst
und dann kannst du per IP auf dieses Gerät connecten und der simuliert dann über einen Browser...
Kein KVM-Switch, im eigentlichen Sinne ein KVM-Switch mit Remote-IP, IP KVM-Switch quasi.
Die gibt es auch teilweise gebraucht, relativ günstig, neu, total sinnlos, sinnlos teuer.
Also das kann man machen, wenn man sein System wirklich am Arsch der Welt steht.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man wirklich solche Anforderungen hat, ist es vielleicht sogar sinnvoller,
man nimmt tatsächlich Server-Hardware, die einen Management-Interface drin hat,
weil wenn du einen Server-Hardware hast mit einem Management-Interface drin,
dann hast du automatisch übers Netzwerk Zugriff auf dein Rechner, auch Remote-Konsole.
Oder wenn das alles nicht hilft, meine bevorzugte Sache mittlerweile,
die Low-Budget-Variante ist, dass man, wenn es ein Linux-Server ist,
dass man eine remote-schaltbare Steckdose nimmt, falls das Ding unwiederbringlich hängt
und dass man halt einstellt, dass der automatisch bootet,
bis zum Passwort-Eingeben von dem Computer,
bis zum Passwort-Eingeben von den Festplatten.
Und dann installiert man sich den SSH-Server drauf, dass der beim Booten schon aktiv ist,
dann kann man nämlich remote über SSH seine Verschlüsse mit Festplatten anlocken
und muss gar nicht hin zum System.
Dann reicht eigentlich fast eine IP-Steckdose.
Die Stimme kommt mir bekannt vor, das ist nicht möglich.
Dann also einfach eine IP-Steckdose, wenn das Ding unwiderbringlich ausschalten, einschalten,
warten, bis es gebootet ist, was wo es einem natürlich nicht hilft,
ist, wenn der Server nicht mehr bootet und komplett im Arsch ist.
Aber dann muss ich es eh neu installieren und dann...
Eigentlich unnütze Sachen, aber cool sind sie.
Ja, neue kannst du dir auch nicht leisten, neue kostet ja 5000 Euro oder so.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich VGA.
Ja, das ist bei den meisten Sachen so.
Der will's aber wissen, ne?
Das ist so ein typisches Ding, es ist komplett unsinnig, aber es ist cool, wenn man das hat.
Schaltet er den KVM-Switch um?
Remote gar nicht, das steht ja vorher an der Konsole.
VGA!
Ja, das ganze Zeug ist VGA.
Also es ist unglaublich, wie sehr im Rechenzentrum die Zeit teilweise stehen geblieben ist, ne?
Von USB-2-Steckern bis VGA-Steckern bis serielle Stecker.
Die haben ja jetzt erst angefangen, dass die HDMI vorne haben.
Also quasi jetzt so.
Also wenn du dir die aktuellste oder die vorletzte Generation kaufst, haben die gerade mal HDMI vorne dran.
Also was sowas angeht, ist das nicht sonderlich advanced.
Aber das liegt auch daran, dass in diesem System oftmals Jahrzehnte alte Dinger stecken.
Die haben teilweise noch, es ist kein Witz, die haben teilweise in halbwegs, ich sag jetzt nicht in aktuellen,
in halbwegs aktuellen Server-Systemen haben die noch eine ATI Rage 3D Pro drinne.
Das ist kein Witz, das ist wirklich kein Witz.
Das ist von, von wann ist denn das? 1996.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von top aktuellen, sondern von irgendwas zu der letzten Jahre.
Da kannst du solche Grafikkarten noch drin finden.
Die machen es nämlich nach der Taktik, was funktioniert und etablierte Firmware-Treiber sonst was hat, kann nix schiefgehen.
Da ist natürlich nicht so eine Karte drin, sondern das ist onboard, auf dem Mainboard drauf sowas.
Da ist ja nicht so eine Karte drin oder so.
Ist da teilweise noch am Start?
Es ist kein Wunder, dass da nur VGA ist.
Und gerade auch die Management-Interface-Geschichten, also dass man per Browser auf den Server drauf kann,
die brauchten bis vor kurzem, aktuell geht's, alle noch einen Java-Client oder einen Browser mit Java-Applets,
also quasi der Teufel in Person, dass die richtig funktioniert haben.
Mittlerweile haben sie es geschafft.
Dell hat die iTrack-Geschichte mit HTML5.
IBM hat die RSA, glaube ich, mittlerweile auch mit HTML5, wobei ich ewig keine IBM-Remote-Konsole mehr hatte.
Und ILO-Geschichten bei HP sind, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile HTML5.
Aber noch nicht lang.
Also erst, erst, keine Ahnung, zwei, drei Jahre.
Das ist, also, erzettmäßig sind die teilweise, kommst du dir vor wie im letzten Jahrtausend, ja?
Oh, das ist eine olle Dell-Kiste.
Von den Farben her könnte es auch eine olle IBM-Kiste sein.
Sieht sich eher alles mehr oder weniger gleich aus.
Ja gut, das muss man nicht.
Man kann sich übrigens mittlerweile wunderbar, wenn man einfach nur rein nach Core-Anzahlen, Rechenleisten guckt,
kann man sich mittlerweile auch wunderbar gebraucht alte Server kaufen.
Also man kann sich ohne Probleme einen alten DL380 oder so kaufen.
Aber das Problem ist, dass die halt meistens relativ laut und relativ stromfressend sind.
Dafür hat man halt auch alles, was man von so einer RZ-Kiste erwartet, bis zum Remote-Interface, ja?
Also wenn man sich einen alten DL380 kaufen will, ich weiß nicht, was da gerade aktuell ist,
die kriegt man ziemlich günstig, ne?
Muss ich mal gucken.
Man kriegt die bestimmt noch, wenn man mich guckt.
Das ist ein bisschen älterer DL380.
Du hast dreimal, du hast zwei Kern, Xeon, E, was ist das hier?
Was ist da drinnen?
Core's vier Kerne, ne?
Du hast acht Kerne, aber das ist halt von 2010.
Das spricht, das Ding braucht halt ordentlich Strom.
Aber wenn einem das egal ist, kriegt man ziemlich günstig, recht rechenleistungsmäßig gute Server-Hardware, ja?
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Warte.
Ich finde diese Network-Tour-Videos übel spannend, was andere Leute haben.
What the fuck, was soll da unten drunter stehen?
Ah, deswegen sind vor allem wir ESX-Gedöns.
Okay, irgendwas custom zusammengebaut ist, oder?
Ist das eine SSD?
Irgendeine olle Grafikkarte?
Storage.
Warum haben die alle so viele olle Storage-Dinger?
Ich meine, ich bilde mir ein, ich habe hier schon relativ viel an Technik-Gedöns.
Aber ich habe auch meinen Rack wieder downsized, downgraded, weil es einfach oversized as fuck war, wie gesagt.
Das habe ich ja schon total aufgezeigt, so sah es halt mal aus.
So sah es halt mal aus.
Der Rechner sollte aber hier unten rein.
Die Kiste ist mittlerweile nicht mehr in Betrieb, weil unnötig oversized.
Ah, hier hat er es.
As you can see, there's already been quite a bit of work done, but it's still got quite a way to go.
Das war Katzen zu gerne.
Sie müssen bald irgendwas erst mal draufsetzen, wenn es gut ist.
Was, was das kostet, ey?
Also, ich sage jetzt aber, warum ich es im Heimbereich bescheuert finde.
Ich meine, das hat was?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 12, 16, 24.
24 Einschübe, das ist daheim total unsinnig.
Willst du es halbwegs sinnvoll füllen, musst du da mindestens 6 oder 8 Terabyte Platten rein machen.
Also, wenn man viel braucht.
Und dann wird es teuer, as fuck, falls man in Richtung 10, 12, 14, was auch immer geht, noch teurer.
Ansonsten, wenn man das mit total billigen, keine Ahnung, 500G oder Terabyte Platten füllt,
dann stellt man die Frage, warum man das betreibt und warum es so viel Strom kostet.
Also, klar, man kriegt vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Performance raus,
wenn man da irgendwie ein total abgedrehtes Rate, Rate 50, sonst was drüber macht oder so.
Das heißt, entweder man macht es mega groß, sodass es quasi irgendwie auch Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Dann hat man mehr Speicher, als man braucht.
Oder aber man macht kleine Platten und es braucht unnütz viel Strom.
Deswegen braucht man das nicht.
Also, wenn man das höchste der Gefühle, was ich als sinnvoll erachte,
wenn man wirklich so ein klassisches Rate mit Storage haben will,
das höchste, was ich als sinnvoll erachte, ist, dass man einen Rate 6 macht.
Ein Rate 6 bedeutet, quasi zwei Platten dürfen kaputt gehen.
Das heißt, auch zwei Platten verliert man Kapazität.
Das ist das höchste der Gefühle, was ich für sinnvoll finde.
Und das ist, sag mal so, man kann das mit vier Platten machen, aber das ist ziemlich beknackt,
weil dann habe ich die Hälfte der Kapazität nicht. Also, sag mal, fünf Platten sollten es mindestens sein.
Fünf, sechs Platten wäre da schon nicht verkehrt.
So, das ist das höchste der Gefühle, was ich im Heimbereich für sinnvoll erachte.
Ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich, ja, aber die CPU ist nicht so das Ding.
Ich persönlich würde es im Heimbereich wirklich ganz simpel halten.
Man nimmt einfach eine fette Platte, die die preisleistungsmäßig passt.
So zehn Terabyte zum Beispiel, vielleicht sogar zwölf, macht einen Rate 1 und gut ist.
Oder aber, man macht ganz was anderes.
Man nimmt tatsächlich nur eine Platte und überlegt sich, welche Daten davon wichtig sind
und macht da einmal, keine Ahnung, am Tag nachts auf eine externe Platte einen Sync.
Das ist die Low-Budget-Variante und die mit Abstand problemloseste Variante.
Wird sowas wie Rate 51 in der Industrie benutzt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir sowas haben.
Was ist denn denn Rate 51 überhaupt?
Also Rate 50 ist klar, das sind gemirrohrte Rate 5s.
Oder, oder, gerate 5te Mirrors?
Was auch immer.
Aber was ist denn Rate 51?
Sind das Rate 1?
Sind das Mirrors gerate 5t?
Wozu das denn?
Da gab es eben noch eine interessante Frage.
Würdest du Software oder Hardware-Rate empfehlen?
Also wenn du jetzt Hardware-Rate-Controller oder Software-Rate...
Also eine Mischung daraus.
Also die einfachste Variante, das zu machen und die im Handling auch am einfachsten ist.
Man holt sich irgendwie einen Rate-Adapter.
Also LSE-Adapter, was es da auch alles gibt.
Stellt dort seinen Rate ein und gut ist.
Das ist die einfachste Variante.
Ich persönlich finde die Kombination aus Host-Adapter.
Also Rate, Rate-Karte, Rate-Adapter, Hostbus-Adapter, was auch immer, wie man das nennen mag.
In Kombination mit einem Software-Rate eigentlich ganz gut.
Also z.B. man nimmt sich irgendeinen LSE-Adapter.
Ach, ich kann mir die Namen nicht merken.
Z.B. sowas hier in der Richtung.
Ein bisschen was Neues vielleicht.
Und dort macht man...
Das ist ein scheiß Beispiel.
Das sagt.
Eher sowas hier.
8 Ports, sowas irgendwie in der Richtung.
Man nimmt sowas.
Am besten mit Mini-SARS-Connector auf SATA.
Und dann benutzt man den nicht als Rate-Adapter.
Sondern einfach nur als ordentlicher Adapter für Ansteuerung von Festplatten.
Und da macht man einen ZFS-Rate drüber.
Oder meinetwegen auch einen Linux-MD-Rate.
Der Vorteil davon, wie ich finde, ist...
Die Dinger gibt es ja auch mit Buffer-Batterie und sonst was.
Der Vorteil davon ist, dass du die Platten an jedem System verwenden kannst, wenn du willst.
Und wenn dir mal der Rate-Controller verrecken sollte.
Was nicht so unwahrscheinlich ist.
Das einzige, was bei mir hier in meinem Rack bisher verreckt ist.
Ist das Ding, was das Ausfall sicher machen soll.
Nämlich das einzige, was bisher verreckt ist.
Hier unten ist die USB.
Also das, was dafür sorgen soll, dass der Kram läuft.
Hat dafür gesorgt, dass es kaputt gegangen ist.
Weil die USB verreckt ist.
Und das kann euch genauso gut mit eurer Karte passieren.
Und wenn du dann eine inkompatible Karte hast, funktioniert dann Rate nicht mehr.
Allgemein muss ich sagen, im Heimbereich ist es auch nicht verkehrt, sich...
Ich hab noch kein Ersatzakku bestellt.
Sich ein fertiges... Was gibt es denn da?
Synology, QNAP, sonst was nass zu kaufen.
Und das ist auch okay.
Oder wenn man wirklich selbst was haben will.
Man kann sich überlegen, ob es wirklich nass...
Ob es wirklich ein Rate sein muss.
Und ob es da nicht ein Rate 1 tut.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile...
Ich hab's ja komplett downsized.
Das hier war mal ein ZFS Rate 1.
Also quasi so eine Rate 5 Geschichte.
Über 13TB Platten.
Das war wahnsinnig.
Oder sogar 12TB? Ich weiß.
Das war total oversized.
Mittlerweile bin ich bei einer 12TB Platte.
Und einer externen Platte, wo ich einmal nachts drauf ersünke.
Also der absolute Noob-Ansatz, wo ich mich früher drüber lustig gemacht hätte.
So ha ha, nur eine Platte und nachts ersünke wie Noob.
Und wie billig und sonst was.
Funktioniert total problemlos.
Und wenn die Platte verreckt, nehme ich einfach die externen Platte und mach sie anstatt dessen dran.
Ja, dann ist es mal kurz down.
Aber ich hab nix da drauf, was so wichtig ist.
Dass ich das High Availability daheim haben müsste.
Und das ist ja das wofür Rate da ist.
Rate ist ja nicht unbedingt dafür da, um...
Also nicht unbedingt primär da.
Um Datenverlust zu verhindern.
Das ist ein Nebeneffekt davon.
Rate ist rein für Uptime.
Also um Datenverlust zu verhindern, ist das einzige was man machen kann ein Backup.
Also sprich ganz billig gesagt, von einer Festplatte das auf die andere Festplatte kopieren.
Das ist das einzige was ich machen kann, um sinnvoll Datenverlust vorzubeugen.
Rate ist für Hochverfügbarkeit, also für Availability da.
Also sprich, ich möchte, dass wenn mir eine Festplatte verreckt,
dass ich quasi weiter benutzen kann on the fly, ohne dass ich das da merke, dass die eine Platte verreckt ist.
Dafür ist ein Rate da.
Also Rate ist kein Backup oder Datenverlust...
Prevention, irgendwie so.
Weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt anders ausdrücken soll.
Also wer wirklich wichtige Sachen hat, sollte gucken, dass er die auf eine externe Festplatte sichert
und sich nicht auf seinen Rate verlassen.
Rate ist auch, also Rate hat ein entscheidendes Nachteil als Backup.
Wenn du eine Sache kaputt machst, ist es auf allen kaputt.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Datei löscht, Linux-mäßig, wenn das RM-Datei
und dann ist die auf dem Rate instant auf allen Platten weg.
Weil Rate ist halt synchron.
Mit einem Backup ist die Datei noch da.
Dann sieht man, dass das keine Backup ist.
Das ist eine reine Availability-Sache, Rate.
So, ja, so viel dazu.
So, jetzt haben wir uns das Video jetzt mal, glaube ich, fertig geguckt, oder?
Ja.
Ah, nee.
Ja, also das finde ich, finde ich unsinnig, sowas Fettes daheim zu betreiben.
Was hat er denn hier für Festplatten drin?
IronWolf110.
Was ist das?
Äh.
Was ist das, das?
Was der hat?
2T SSD, oder?
Sind das die Dinger?
Das ist ganz schön teuer, wenn er das voll machen will, ne?
Also, wenn er 24-mal, das sind dann, was?
24-mal, was waren das, 280 Euro?
Da hast du busy was zu tun, wenn du dein Last damit mit SSDs vollstopfen willst.
Da würde ich mir lieber einen ordentlichen Rechner verkaufen.
Der hat die 480, okay, da kostet die Hälfte ungefähr.
Oder noch weniger, aber die 480 GE sogar.
Da geht das sogar.
120, okay, also Kalk.
Das ist immer noch ordentlich.
Ah, sind da nur 3000 Euro.
Wobei, wobei das geht, wenn man sich überlegt, was beispielsweise 12TB Festplatten kosten,
ist das nicht so viel, wie es sonst wäre.
Das ist etwas nicht so verkehrt.
Info gab es, nee, gab es keinen Sub.
Coser Bees ist neu hier, hallo, moin.
2020, ich mache kein PC-Kaufberatungsvideo, ich mache ein Video zu meinem neuen PC,
wenn ich mir den endlich mal kaufen könnte.
Ich hoffe ja, dass AMD und Nvidia das endlich mal hinkriegen.
Braucht man sowas für einen Home-Sofer?
Nö, gar nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich bin mittlerweile auch bei einer 12TB Platte und einem nächtlichen Air-Sync
auf eine externe Platte, fertig.
Ich habe downgraded as fuck von meiner 4AE-Kiste.
Was sagst du zu Version-Control im File-System?
Du mein Snapshots, Snapshots ist eine praktische Geschichte.
Ja, Snapshots sind äußerst praktisch.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt dauerhaft, aber gerade im Zusammenspiel vielleicht mit irgendwelchen
Containerzeugen oder so, da sind Snapshots wirklich praktisch.
Machen wir einen Snapshot, wenn das nach dem Upgrade abkackt,
Snapshot Rollback gut ist.
Also Snapshots sind wirklich eines der coolsten Features an ZFS und BTRFS.
Ich weiß, dass die coolen Leute es Butter, Better, wie auch immer FS aussprechen,
aber ich sag BTRFS.
Weil sich die anderen Sachen für mich irgendwie falsch anhören.
Viel besser als erwartet, ich kühle meinen PC mit Leitungswasser.
Ja klar, warum soll das nicht funktionieren?
Es verkalkt vielleicht ein bisschen mit der Zeit, ne?
Oh, weiß nicht, warum soll das nicht gehen?
Leute, es ist 14 Uhr, ich würde sagen, wir sind alle wach.
Ich habe übelst Kohldampf.
Wir sind heute nicht so weit gekommen mit Videos, glaube ich.
Aber ihr kennt das ja, wir speichern das jetzt wieder.
Bookmark all tabs.
Und zwar, neuer Ordner.
Es war vom 30.08.
Ach nee, Moment.
Sessions.
Ah, wie kann man die nicht verschieben?
Safe. Sessions.
Da ist der 8.
Gut.
Sehr schön.
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe die Woche ein bisschen wenig gestreamt.
Ich war im C++-Land unterwegs.
Das wollte ich euch nicht antun.
Da wäre ich nämlich permanent nur am Meckern.
Und ich war tatsächlich relativ viel unterwegs.
Das glaubt man mir gar nicht, ja.
So ein bisschen in freier Wildbahn, im Wald und so.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Ja.
Aber ich hoffe, dass ich morgen noch mal eine Runde streamen kann.
Vielleicht wird es die Woche wieder ein bisschen mehr.
What?
Weiß ich doch nicht.
Traffic ist in der Konfig und gerade in der Fehlermeldung.
Voll kacke.
Hast du es über Docker?
Hast du irgendeine Docker-Compose-Konfig?
Oder wie machst du deinen Traffic?
Traffic-Konfig.
Also Traffic-Konfig von Hand.
Über Konfigfalls ist eklig.
Wenn du einfach...
Was willst du mit Traffic machen?
Willst du einfach nur ein mega easy Reverse-Proxy machen?
Dann würde ich das nicht mit Traffic machen.
Nimmst du das hier.
Du brauchst einfach nur ein Reverse-Proxy, der mit zwei Zeilen konfiguriert ist.
Nimm den hier.
So.
Sowas hier.
Example.
Quickstart Guide.
Also sprich...
Das ist total einfach.
Zu konfigurieren.
Du brauchst zwei Zeilen.
Die Gist dafür.
Also wenn du das nicht mit Docker...
Ach alles im Docker.
Dann würde ich ein Traffic nehmen.
Weil die Caddy-Config ist schon easy as fuck.
Das ist alles was du brauchst.
Die zwei Zeilen.
Proxy, Slash, irgendwas.
Fertig.
Wenn es ein Traffic ist, dann würde ich es mit Docker-Compose in Kombination machen.
Dann würde ich es mit Docker-Compose in Kombination machen.
Da kann ich aber nicht sagen woher die Fehlermeldung jetzt kommt.
Keine Ahnung.
By the way, brauche ich SSL, wenn ich es nur im Heimnetzwerk haben will?
Naja, brauchen.
Brauchen nicht.
Außer du verwendest was, was...
So wie WebRTC, was unbedingt SSL haben will.
Ich finde es aber mittlerweile doof, kein SSL mehr zu haben.
Einfach weil es so einfach ist vom Setup.
Gerade mit Let's Encrypt und DNS-Challenge
ist es ziemlich einfach, das automatisch auch im lokalen Netzwerk aufzusetzen.
Voraussetzung ist natürlich, du hast ein Domain,
die dir gehört, wo du auch DNS-Settings machen kannst.
Das ist aber kein Problem, weil die kriegst du für 3,50 Euro im Jahr.
Irgendwelche Domains.
Wir sehen uns.
Ich sage nicht nachher, weil wahrscheinlich wird das nichts.